Two,
one,
boom.
Welcome back.
Ms Dot Peterson.
Thank you.
How are you?
Not too bad.
How are you doing?
Doing good man.
You look like a,
um,
a man who was dealing with a
considerable amount of stress but is
handling it well.
Yeah.
Well,
I hope that's true.
I think the first part of it's true.
I hope the second part is true.
I read that you were denied a grant for
the first time in your history as an
academic.
Yes.
And you think this is all based on your
outspoken and very public,
um,
denouncing the political correctness and
have all this stuff that you've been
going through over the past more than a
year now?
I don't know because I haven't got the
full commentary on the grant yet.
I only found out that it was denied and
it takes the granting agency a while to
send out the full report.
I've heard from other people,
I know some other people who I would
consider relatively high profile
researchers.
Uh,
walls also didn't get funded this round.
So there might be multiple reasons,
but I can't help suspect that the fact
that the grant application concentrated
on delineating the personality
characteristics of politically correct
belief might've had something to do with
it.
So still a taboo subject.
It's fascinating that thinking and
thinking and pondering and examining
certain types of behavior would still be
a taboo subject.
Yeah.
Is Amazing.
Alright.
And becoming more taboo all the time.
I would say.
I don't think the universities are have.
I think they're getting worse still and
it will be awhile before they get
better.
I shouldn't say that.
So globally,
but certainly the case with the
humanities and much of the social
sciences,
but it seems globally,
I mean not necessarily in terms of all
the different subjects but certainly in
terms of what you teach and what your
involved in and it just.
It's so
me,
I hate to use the word,
but it's so regressive to put
restrictions on the examining of
thinking in a university.
I mean it's kind of crazy.
I mean what,
what you went through in one of your
most recent public speeches where they
allowed these kids to be in the room
with you with bullhorns and they were
screaming event Jamie,
see if he could find the video that.
What was the name?
Master master.
Master University.
Yeah,
and you were giving your speech and
there was supposed to be some other
people involved.
They backed out and you decided to
continue on,
so you're standing there in front of
these people that were there to hear you
talk and there's a group of kids with
bull horns like literally and shouting
and yelling and chanting with signs in
the room,
just completely disrupting what you're
doing.
And they allowed this all to happen.
Airhorns as well.
So.
Yeah.
And they blowing air horns quite
close.
To me.
That was the one thing I really objected
to because airhorns actually happened to
be quite loud.
No,
no,
that's.
It's actually an assault on your ears.
It's very bad for your hearing.
Like you're not supposed to be in a room
with those without hearing protection.
They're supposed to be like for like
scary things like play some of this
Jamie so we can hear how crazy.
Yes.
Yelling,
shut him down.
No freedom for hate speech and the hate
speech thing has like prince symbol meet
some sort of Martian language.
Like what the fuck is that that they
have on that note?
No freedom for hate speech.
I guess it's a poly gender,
a symbol of some sort.
There's a fist in it.
One of the things that was really not so
good about all of that was that a lot of
the people who were protesting were
standing behind a hammer and sickle
banner,
you know,
which just absolutely amazes me because
I still haven't been able to quite
figure this out.
I can't figure out why you couldn't do
that with a Nazi symbol,
but you can do that with a hammer and
sickle,
you know it's.
There's a reason.
Maybe it's because the Nazi doctrine was
so explicitly racist,
but God,
it's not like the hammer and sickle
wasn't equally murderous or be actually
quite profoundly more murderous as it
turned out.
So and I how,
how people can not steal,
no,
that is beyond me.
And,
and to rally behind a banner like that
without realizing what they're doing or
even worse,
realizing it and still organizing
themselves behind it,
explained about hate speech.
No,
there's no real communicating with,
with people who are demonstrating that
they're in a kind of trance,
you know,
and I went up to try to talk to you a
couple of them and,
but when you look at people who are in
that state of mind,
they're not looking at you as if you're
a human being,
you know,
you're the,
you're the target of their
conceptualizations.
You're the realization of their
Of course they didn't listen to
anything.
I said,
well hardly anyone did.
Although I got to talk outside because I
took everybody outside and then spoke
out there for awhile.
And when you were outside with his still
yelling and bull horns.
But what happened?
I went outside and I stood on a couple
of benches so.
And the people that wanted to hear kind
of made a circle around me and that more
or less by chance pushed all the
protesters to the back so they could so
that I could address the people that
actually wanted me to actually want it
to listen to what I was saying.
And so did you have a dialogue with them
or did you give a speech and how did
that work?
I didn't have a dialogue at all with the
protesters.
I mean with the people that came to see.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that worked out okay.
Once I got outside and I.
I mean I wasn't particularly upset with
the fact that the protesters had showed
up.
I mean practically speaking because I'm
in this peculiar situation where if the
protest is show up,
that's good.
And if they don't show up,
that's good too.
It's good if they show up because I have
access to,
to a youtube audience obviously.
And then it gets filmed and the films
get put together and that get puts,
that gets put online.
And generally speaking,
when the social justice types have come
after me,
they've done a pretty admirable job of
discrediting themselves and so that
seems to be all to the good.
And then if they let me speak well then
I get to speak and I can put that on
youtube.
So it's,
it's a very strange situation for me
because as long as I don't do anything
too stupid or anything,
any stupider than I have done,
let's say I seem to come out okay.
And like I'm not,
I'm certainly not counting on that
continuing and I'm not a,
I'm,
I'm surprised by it.
But so far it seems to be working out.
So you know Perrey.
Yes.
The way you handled it is admirable.
The way you kept your cool and just
continued talking and didn't flip out
and didn't,
didn't give in,
didn't succumb to the provocation.
It's because they were obviously
provoking you and they are obviously.
I just don't understand how the
university allows them to do that.
How they allow them to be in that room,
first of all,
with those air horns,
which are really bad for anybody in that
room.
Who's near them?
It causes hearing damage.
Yeah.
Well,
in the one person who is,
who is Air Horn me was really quite a,
I would say,
let's say forward about it,
you know,
they were coming close enough to me to,
to do some damage and,
and,
but,
you know,
I,
I have seen the odd person at those
rallies that really isn't well put
together,
you know,
people I look in their eyes and I think
no,
uh,
you're,
you're definitely here for the wrong
reasons and I think it's more
characteristic often to the guys that I
see at the events rather than the women.
I mean,
I'm not sure about that.
I'm obviously speculating,
but you know,
I have a reasonably good clinical
intuition and some of the guys I see at
those events there,
I don't know what their story is,
man.
I don't know what they're up to.
I guess they're,
what are they trying to do?
Be Allies of the women for their own
nefarious purposes.
I mean,
that's what it looks like to me,
you know?
Well,
there's certainly an issue with that.
It's a,
it's a common thread with men,
especially in the male feminists
category that they,
they align themselves with these women
as allies and as this,
you know,
they take this moral high ground and
there this person that's going to show
you know,
other men how to do feminism and how to
behave with women and they're really
just sort of,
they're mining the situations for social
points,
for social sexual points.
My sexual.
Absolutely.
There's something seriously creepy about
it.
I mean,
I saw too that that guy at the Berkeley,
the reason Berkeley demonstration,
the guy who hit someone with a bike lock
bag and he was hiding behind women and
then he darted
out and just nailed the guy with a bike
law with what turned out to be a bike
law guy.
It was just hanging there talk to you.
It wasn't being violent.
He wasn't doing anything.
And by the way,
that guy turned out to be a professor.
They found that guy.
Yeah.
And so has that been verified?
All of that.
There's photographs of him.
There's photographs of his face.
They compared the,
his eyes to the professors.
Are they know that the guy was there and
then the guy will aligns himself with
Marxism and he's just like a communist
slash socialist professor who's very
adamantly against a right wing ideology
and this kind of Shit.
So He,
I'm pretty sure that that's the guy.
Yeah.
Well I kind of followed that and I
noticed that.
I mean for,
as far as I'm concerned,
watching what he did,
that's the true face of those people.
It's assault.
I mean he hit a guy with a deadly
weapon.
Yeah.
I mean I also thought it was blackly
comic that it was a bike lock.
I mean that just figures,
you know so.
Well,
it's just the idea that you could just
walk up to someone you don't like the
way they think and hit them in the head
with a metal thing.
It's just so.
It's so crazy and so delusional and so
indicative of someone who looks at a
person as the other.
You're not looking at it as a human
being or disagrees with you like.
And not only that,
a young human being talk about a lack of
empathy.
I mean,
you're expecting this 20 year old guy or
however old the guy wasn't get hit in
the head.
You're expecting him to have his
ideology down solid and not be
influenced by peers or not.
Be Curious about what this argument is,
but the guy wasn't even yelling
anything.
He was just standing there.
Yeah.
Well that's Kinda what I thought about
this.
The protesters at mcmaster too,
you know,
it's partly,
I don't get upset.
It's like I look at these kids that are
out there protesting,
you know,
apart from the professional professional
protestor types and I think,
well Jesus,
they've been served so badly by the
education system that it's absolutely
beyond belief.
You know,
they're basically being sent out as
avatars have this pathological
postmodern movement by their professors
who are themselves too cowardly to show
up.
Generally speaking certainly aren't,
aren't brave enough to debate me because
they do show up.
They're like this guy with a mask on
hitting people in the head who was a
professor.
Yeah.
Well they don't believe in dialogue.
You know,
it's not part of their.
It's not part of the postmodern ethos to
have a dialogue with people you don't
agree with,
so you weren't able to talk to anyone
that opposed you?
Not so far.
Not In any serious sense.
Were you able to talk to anyone that had
the hammer and sickle sign and and ask
them like,
do you understand what this stands for?
What does this mean to you?
Like what?
What?
What are you trying to project by having
the sun?
No,
no,
wasn't,
wasn't possible at that venue.
I mean,
like I said,
whenever I got close to anybody that was
protesting that it,
there was no one to one human
interaction,
you know?
I mean I can tell when someone's going
to be willing to communicate with me and
when they've kind of got cold eyes,
like a cod fish,
you know,
whatever they're looking at has nothing
to do with me or very little to do with
me.
Well,
that seems to me to be one of the
weirder aspects of this thing that
you're going through this,
this,
these,
all these series of altercations that
you're going through is the lack of
discourse.
And there was this one that you went on
to on television when we talked about
the last time you were here with.
It's very bizarre and drudging this
person that was saying there's no
gender,
there is no biological basis for gender,
which is just complete insanity and you
shooting that down and might be
insanity,
but it's Canadian law now or soon to be
federally.
So it's insanity for sure.
But.
But it's the kind of insanity that's
going to have legal force very soon.
What is it specifically that there's no
seat?
Well,
with Bill [inaudible],
which was the bill that I was
complaining about or criticizing,
let's say there's a variety of
surrounding policy documents that are
derived from the Ontario Human Rights
Commission and they,
they indicate quite clearly that year to
regard biological sex,
gender identity,
gender expression and sexual proclivity
as varying independently.
Which of course they don't by any
stretch of the imagination.
They're so tightly correlated that well,
you can't use correlation to imply cause
or to infer causality.
But Jesus,
when the correlations are above point
nine five,
you have to start wondering if there's
actually not some causal link and it's
absurd to me that we really even have to
have that discussion.
But the notion,
and this is being taught to schoolkids
this,
this isn't,
this is mainstream doctrine.
Joe The gender.
Look up the gender Unicorn.
That's a fun thing to look up.
What is the Gender Unicorn?
The Gender Unicorn is this little happy
symbol that's being marketed to
children,
you know,
in elementary school,
uh,
describing to them the fact that
biological sex,
gender identity,
gender expression and sexual proclivity
very independently,
they're going after them very young.
And so that's part of the,
that's part of the school system now in
many,
many places.
So in many ways it's sort of an
indoctrination.
They're trying to say that the gender
Unicorn,
a Unicorn man,
check that thing out.
Gender identity,
female woman,
girl,
male man,
boy,
other gender,
gender expression,
feminine,
Masculine.
Other sex assigned at birth,
female,
Male,
other intersex.
Ooh,
like aliens,
physically attracted to men,
women,
other,
other gender s emotionally attracted.
So what you do if you're a kid is you
put a little marker there on the Arrow
to show where you're located on all
those independent dimensions.
And obviously if you look at the,
at the style of the Gender Unicorn,
you can tell what sort of age it's aimed
at [inaudible] that looks like it's
aimed for.
Certainly not aimed at kids over,
I would say 10.
Yeah.
Why does the Gender Unicorn have a
double helix DNA symbol where it's penis
or vagina.
So should they.
That's to indicate that there's no law.
There's no such thing as biology,
I presume,
but why?
That's how ironic might say so yeah,
it's a weird place to put it over the
crotch of the UNICORNS.
There's,
there's an indefinite number of weird
things about that.
But yes,
there's the ginger ginger,
gender bread person that's A.
Oh,
genderbread person has a male symbol,
female symbol.
And then uh,
what am I all together with a circle
where the,
a whole not a whole circle.
So strange,
problematic place for the circle.
I would say very assumptive.
I would say so,
yes.
Yes.
I don't like that at all.
I feel triggered.
Well,
the whole thing is it's so bizarre,
but what's even more bizarre is the lack
of dialogue.
I feel like you're in a weird position
where there's a tremendous amount of
support for you outside of the academic
system.
People like me,
people like so many people that support
your youtube videos,
so many people that read about you
online and you're experiencing all this
backlash at like mcmasters and these
sort of things,
but there's people are not engaging you
and the way they are,
they're keeping from engaging.
You is saying that you are demonstrating
hate speech,
hate speech.
There's racism.
The reason I'd be called a racist is
because I complained.
I criticized the University of Toronto's
decision to use the Toronto chapter of
black lives matter as policy advisers
and the reason I did that was because
the two women who founded black lives
matter in Toronto,
let's say they have,
let's say they have questionable
reputations and leave it at that and so
apparently that makes me racist because.
Well,
you don't question them because they're
not.
Well.
He.
One of them has publicly stated that
white people are inferior to black
people because they don't have enough
melanin in their skin and Melanin is the
chemical that communicates cosmically so
that you're spiritually enlightened.
That was one essential claim and the
other one is is embroiled in lawsuit
with the University of Toronto Students
Union for essentially she's been accused
of embezzling,
embezzling with a couple of cronies,
about $400,000
from the coffers of the student's Union,
so I felt that perhaps those weren't the
best people to for the University of
Toronto to be associating with when
they're formulating their anti racist
policies.
Well clearly that makes you racist
clearly,
clearly.
Well,
it's unfair as well altogether in one
little lump sump.
That's man thing.
But what's really fascinating about that
is like you're not saying anything about
black people,
you're saying about two individuals to
individuals that you and you're,
you're having very specific.
You know,
everybody that makes up a group is the
same.
You see,
you have to understand that men and
women,
right?
That's right.
Except men and women,
men and women can be anything.
Well,
there's an interesting angle on the
transsexual thing to a because these
activists,
they stand out and claim they're
standing
for oppressed communities right in,
first of all,
they identify the identity group that
they're activated activating on,
on the part of as a community and then
they imply that it's a generous
community and then they state that
because they happen to be members of
that community by their own admission,
let's say,
or by their own declaration.
That's a better word that they are now
legitimate representatives of that
community.
And one of the things that's been quite
fascinating to me since this has
occurred is that I've had a very,
a comparatively large number of letters
from transgender people about 35 so far
and every one of those except one was
positive.
They are not happy about my sampling of
the Trans Community,
which isn't,
you know,
it's not a random sample or anything
like that,
but 35 letters is a lot.
When the community of people is actually
quite small and they're not happy at all
that they don't.
They don't.
They're not happy to be so publicly
discussed now because many of them would
just assume have some privacy,
you know,
and they're already having trouble
fitting in.
They don't regard these people as
legitimate representatives.
They don't believe they're not
homogenous in their political
viewpoints,
you know,
and,
and they're not necessarily fans of the
people who are playing gender bender
games because many of the transsexuals
who are,
let's say serious about it,
you know,
for,
for lack of a better way of describing
it,
aren't happy that this has become a kind
of a fad essentially,
and that they're being used by the
politically correct types to further
their political agenda.
So that's quite cool to because it isn't
obvious to me at all that the attitude
that I have towards the situation is
actually different in any genuine sense.
Then the attitude that at least a
substantial minority of the transsexual
people themselves have,
and there's plenty of them on youtube
who are complaining about the social
justice appropriation of their,
of their identity.
Well,
I don't even know if they have a
movement.
They're not a community,
right?
I mean that they're not a community.
I mean a community is in continual
contact with one another.
They have something that directs their
actions in common.
I mean,
but you know,
on the,
on the postmodern end of the spectrum,
if you have some identifiable group
feature,
then that means you're one of that group
and that everything that you do
indicates indicates only that means
there are believers in,
in race and gender and sex.
They believe in the reality of those of
those categories far more than anybody
on the right as far as I can tell.
So it's very peculiar and,
and unnerving,
so,
so and,
and widespread and powerful and all of
those things.
So it's very peculiar that they are not
into labels unless it suits their
purposes.
They're not in the labels or into a
generalizing behavior unless it suits
their purpose.
And also another thing that's weird
to me is that whenever something becomes
an issue that becomes discussed,
that becomes a hot button issue,
which clearly transgender rights,
whether it's the North Carolina bill,
to keep transgender people out of the
bathrooms that associate with that
identify with that they identify with,
with whatever gender it is,
whenever there's some sort of a hot
button issue,
there becomes this thing where a bunch
of people seek attention through those
issues and these people,
uh,
use whatever issue it is to be,
it becomes like a part of their
identity,
like becoming an activist and,
and,
and really being very vocal about it.
Whereas though the,
the actual cause itself gets muddied in
the cult of personality and it gets
muddied in these personal wishes and
ideas that the people who are seeking to
get attention by communicating about
these ideas sort of soak in.
You know,
it,
it just becomes a lot about human nature
and human behavior more than it is about
the actual issue.
And so it's an opportunity.
Each of these hypothetically contentious
issues is an opportunity for a certain
kind of sterile drama to unfold.
And the drama is always the same.
I mean,
you can see that in the,
in the,
um,
demonstrations say with regards to my
talks,
it doesn't matter what I'm talking about
and it actually doesn't matter what I've
ever said,
all that matters is that there was an
occasion and an excuse to trot out the
ideology and to end to pathetically
mouth the same unbelievably sterile and
chaotic phrases.
You know,
I mean the,
I think the people at mcmaster,
the protesters could only muster about
three chance and two of them were
seriously obscene and I mean,
which I don't care about except that
it's so mindlessly unimaginative in what
it is they're operating at such a low
level of,
of intellectual effort.
And,
and of course Egged on by their
pathological postmodern professors who
are hiding behind them,
like,
like scared,
scared weasels.
So there's shut him down.
That was the big one,
racist,
transphobic,
homophobic,
all these things without substance
because there's no piece of shit was the
other one that was quite.
That was quite a transphobic piece of
shit or just more,
more,
more specific,
which was rather flattering and all of
that.
So it's a.
You don't seem to have any hate towards
trans people at all?
No,
I mean from the discussions I've had
with you both on and off the air,
the idea of you being transphobic seems
so inaccurate because you seem pretty
accepting about anybody,
whether it's a trans person,
a gay person,
it's not.
The issue is a lot more concerned about
whether or not people are honest.
I mean that's what I,
that's what,
that's my fundamental orientation.
And so my fundamental concern,
I mean I don't expect people to be 100
percent honest because of course who is,
you know,
I mean that's a hell of a required
standard to hold anyone to.
But all of that is smoke and mirrors and
I think the people who are after me know
it,
but let's get through some of that just
to,
just to sort of establish it for people.
Maybe they don't know what issues do.
Do you have any issue whatsoever with
someone being transgender?
No,
I don't have any issue with that.
What I have an issue with is that is
that I don't like to see the postmodern
Neil Marxists use the trans sexual issue
as a lever for pushing forward their
political nonsense and I said that right
from the beginning and the videos are
made to begin with.
The reason I wouldn't use the word Z and
[inaudible] and all those other made up
words,
however many there are now is because
I'm not willing to cede the linguistic
territory to postmodern radicals.
I'm not doing that.
And they say,
well,
we're doing it on behalf of the
oppressed transsexual people.
And I think,
yeah,
well that's what you say,
but there's no reason I should believe
that.
Don't believe anything you say.
I think you're contemptible,
cowardly,
ideologically motivated cult like
corruptors of the youth.
So why would I use your language?
Well,
let's,
let's unpack that because one of the
things that I find fascinating is how
few transgender people want to use those
words that transgender people seem to
want to identify with whatever gender
they like.
If,
if you are a male to female transgender
person,
you would prefer to be called the.
She like Caitlyn Jenner and pretty much
everybody calls the artist formerly
known as Bruce Jenner,
Caitlyn Jenner.
Right.
That's.
That's just.
It's like if you had a look at how many
people just openly accept that it's
pretty.
It's pretty well accepted.
Right.
Most transgender people prefer that they
prefer a female to male.
I prefer they prefer to be a man now.
I'm a man now.
Okay.
Bob,
Dick,
whatever your name is that's in.
There's not a lot of ze Zer.
Well,
no,
you're not out of the loop.
The other thing is those are all third
person pronouns.
It's like,
I don't.
I'm not going to call you a third person
Pronoun while we're sitting here.
You know,
I never would.
If I'm referring to you when I'm talking
to someone else,
call her name.
Right.
Well,
I could use your name,
your name.
I might use he then,
but I don't know.
Well,
it's just all of it is palpably absurd.
I think it's always hard to get the
level of analysis for this sort of
issue.
Correct,
you know,
because the people who were pushing it
forward say,
well,
we're against harassment and and and
discrimination and and they attributed
all the moral virtue to themselves,
but then what I see is that they're
utilizing a group,
a very small minority group who already
have enough problems,
in my estimation,
for for nothing other than
straightforward political purposes.
I don't buy the the warm hearted,
it'll all inclusive.
Love that.
The people who are pushing this of thing
for we claim to display.
I don't see that at all.
What I see mostly as
resentment and the desire to undermine
and I'm quite familiar with the
postmodern philosophy,
not as familiar as I could be and also
reasonably familiar with its underlying
Marxism and there's nothing touchy feely
about any of that.
I can tell you the postmodernist,
the best you can do with poetry,
postmodernist philosophy is emerged.
Nihilistic.
That's the best.
The worst case is that you're kind of an
article,
social revolutionary.
That's directionless except that you
want to tear things apart or,
or that you end up depressed,
which I see happening to students all
the time because the postmodernist like
rip out the remaining fee structures of
their foundations,
of their ethical foundations.
So just to be really clear for anybody
tuning in your issues are absolutely not
with someone who identifies with the
gender other than their biological
gender,
as long as they're not using that to
promote a political agenda.
And I don't care about the gender thing.
That's doesn't mean anything.
Well,
it's someone,
it's,
it's a personal preference,
personal issue personally,
personal issue.
And um,
and I would also deal with it on an
individual to individual
basis.
It varies just as much as they're
extremely masculine men,
extremely feminine women.
And there's a broad spectrum of human
beings in between and each one should be
dealt with on an individual basis.
Yes,
based on what they want.
But when you're talking about these made
up words,
what it seems like as it some people
trying to push these made up words and
turn them mainstream.
Now the question is,
what's the motivation behind that?
Is this unnecessary thing?
Are there so many people that are of
asexual or have some sort of mean?
What would be a z or preserve?
What is that supposed to be?
Is that supposed to be a male or a
female?
Is it's supposed to be a sexual or is it
supposed to be a nonconformist lean?
What is it?
Well,
it's supposed to be someone who who's
gender isn't specified,
right?
Who is neither male nor female,
or maybe they say they say technically
in the,
in the policy guidelines is anywhere or
nowhere on the spectrum,
and that's actually in the policy
guidelines in Ontario where or nowhere
and the nowhere.
I mean these are.
These are policies that are,
that are going to determine law,
right?
That within which the law is going to be
interpreted.
I don't even know what nowhere on the
spectrum means.
I don't understand what that means.
Doesn't mean anything.
It's nonsense.
So you have.
So here's the options,
right?
There's someone who identifies with the
opposite gender of their biological
birth.
So there's a man,
for instance,
who identifies as a woman,
everyone's cool with that.
Whatever your name is,
whatever you would like to be called,
whether it's Wendy or Mike or whatever
it is.
That would be the noise that you want
people to make with their mouth.
That means you.
That's it right now,
whether you're a he or a she.
Outside of that,
that's where things get squirrely.
So third person is the only issue.
The only issue is like say if we were
talking to Jamie,
Jamie just decided to.
He's going to be Jamie now.
He still Jamie Jamie's girl's name too.
I know girls named Jamie so he could be
Jamie and Jamie decides he's a woman and
now he wants to be called.
She was like,
okay,
okay.
She Alright Jamie.
Now your she.
But when it gets to like xer and Z and
the 78 different gender pronouns,
it seems to a person outside of it
person who's CIS gendered.
It seems pretty,
pretty bizarre and it seems pretty
preposterous and it seems pretty
indulgent and it seems like there's
something else going on in this.
That's the thing.
It's,
it's something else going on park.
That is what concerns me.
There is something else going on in it.
If there wasn't something else going on,
I'm a relatively obscure professors,
amateurish youtube videos on a
relatively obscure piece of Canadian
legislation.
Wouldn't have had any effect.
Right?
It would have just disappeared,
right?
It didn't,
but you're not because there's more
going on than than a straightforward
issue surrounding the pronoun use and
everybody knows it or everybody feels
that at least what it seems like from
someone outside of academia,
someone like me is it seems like you're
pushing back against something that they
are really trying hard to establish and
then it's some kind of control at some
kind of control with how people behave
and communicate and it's not.
It's not like a societal thing.
It's a very small,
isolated group of people that seem to be
trying to indoctrinate others into their
ways and they become.
They're becoming a very vocal and very
angry and verbally violent about your
opposition to their controlling the way
they can that other people,
they don't like poking holes in the
radiology and the post.
The Post here,
we could lay it out quickly because I've
been,
I've been thinking about how to
communicate this properly and so the
thing about the postmodernists,
and I'm going to speak mostly about
Jacques Derrida because all consider him
in the central villain.
Now he actually,
he,
he may make a point explain who he is.
Well,
he's a,
he's a French philosopher,
French intellectual who became quite
popular in the late 19 seventies and
then was introduced to North America
through the Yale Department of English
and of course English literature is one
of the disciplines that has become
entirely corrupt.
And so Derrida wasn't Marxist to begin
with,
but that fell out of favor because it
turned out the Marxist political
doctrine kept producing evil empires and
even radical left French intellectuals
were forced to admit that by the mid 19
seventies,
you know,
they'd put their head in the sand for 20
years,
50 years really thoroughly in the sand
and made sure their ears were full too.
But by the mid 19 seventies,
the evidence that that was the case was
so overwhelming that even a French
intellectual couldn't deny it anymore.
And so they started to play sleight of
hand with the Marxist ideas.
So instead of trying to promote the
revolution of the working class against
the,
against the capitalist class,
let's say they started to play identity
politics and said,
well,
we can just separate everybody into
oppressed versus so presser,
but we don't have to do it on economic
grounds.
And so we and we can call it power
instead of economics.
So that was part of it.
And then the other thing about the
fundamental critique that Derrida
focused on this is this is this is
really worth laying out because that the
problem that he discovered,
the postmodernist discovered was
discovered by a variety of other people
at the same time in other disciplines.
So for example,
among the people who were studying
artificial intelligence since the early
19 sixties,
it was always supposed that we'd be able
to make machines that could move around
in a natural environment without too
much problem.
And the reason we could do that was
because the world in some sense,
was just made out of simple objects.
They are,
they are.
And what you have to do is look at them
and you see them,
and that's vision,
and then the complex problem is not how
to see or what to see,
but how to act in reference to what you
see.
But it turned out that the AI people ran
into this problem,
essentially sometimes known as the frame
problem.
And the frame problem is,
is that there's almost an infinite
number of ways to look at a finite set
of objects.
So the fact that that vision,
for example,
it turns out to be way,
way,
way more complicated than anybody ever,
ever estimated.
In fact,
you can't actually solve the vision
problem until you solve the embodiment
problems.
So,
uh,
an artificial intelligence that doesn't
have a body can't really see because
seeing is actually the mapping of the
world on to action.
And so that was figured out more or less
by a robotics engineer called Rodney
Brooks.
But,
but what's at the bottom of this is the
idea that any set of phenomena can be
seen a very large number of ways.
So like there's a bunch of pens in front
of me here,
you know,
and when I look at the,
my brain basically notes that there are
grippable object with which I can write.
So I see the function like,
like if you look at a beanbag,
you see a chair,
not because it's got four legs and a
seat and a back,
but because you can sit on it and,
and most of what we see in the world,
we actually see functionally rather than
see as an object and then interpret the
object and then figure out what to do.
So the function of the object
constraints,
our interpretation.
But there's an endless number of
interpretations.
So for example,
if I was going to paint that paint on
canvas,
this set of pens and try to do it in a
photo realistic way,
I would be looking at tiny details of
these objects that the multiple shades
of red that are there and the multiple
shades of white and black.
And you know,
I would decompose it in many,
many ways.
And so the AI guys ran into this
problem,
which was that looking at the world
turned out to be exceptionally complex
and that's still being solved now.
Okay?
In literature,
the same thing.
What?
What
the postmodernists realized was that if
you took a complex book,
let's say the Bible for example,
or a shakespeare play,
there's an endless number of potential
interpretations that you can derive from
it because it's so complex and so
sophisticated.
So imagine that.
Well,
you can interpret the word,
you can interpret the phrase,
you can interpret the sentence,
you can interpret the paragraph,
you can interpret the chapter.
Let's say you have to interpret that
within the confines of the entire work.
Then have the entire tradition and then
within the context of discussion that
you're currently having and all of those
things affect how you're going to
interpret the play.
So there's an so that their conclusion
was,
well,
there's an infinite number of ways to
interpret a text.
And then their conclusion was,
well,
there's an infinite number of ways to
interpret the world.
And there's,
there's a way in which that's correct.
And so the next conclusion was,
there's no right way to do it so you
could do it any old way.
And then their next conclusion was,
oh,
and this is where the Marxism creeped up
again.
Oh,
people interpret the world in a way that
facilitates their acquisition of power.
Now that's where the bloody theory
starts to get corrupt because yes,
a bit but also know,
right?
Because,
and this is why they're wrong,
this is why they're wrong.
You see,
the world is complicated beyond our
ability to comprehend.
So there is a very large number of ways
you can interpret it,
but,
but you have to extract out from the
world a way a game from your
interpretation that you can actually
play.
So if the lesson that you extract from
hamlet is you should kill your family
and yourself,
then we might say that that's not a very
functional interpretation,
right?
Because first of all,
people are going to object to that,
right?
It ends your life.
It ends many people's lives.
People are going to object to it and it
isn't a game that you can play over and
over again in the world,
so when we're,
when we're interacting with the world,
you see what we're trying to do is to
extract out a set of tools that we can
use to function in the world because
we're constrained by the world so that
we don't suffer too much and so that the
things that we need in order to continue
can be provided and we need to extract
those out in a way that other people
will so that other people will cooperate
and compete with us in a peaceful and
maintainable way.
So then you think,
well,
we have to extract out an interpretation
that allows us to live and thrive over
multiple periods of time in multiple
environments.
Well,
we're doing the same thing with other
individuals who are motivated the same
way.
So there's a tremendous number of
constraints on our interpretations and
the postmodernists don't care about that
at all.
All they do is say,
well,
no,
no.
You can interpret the way the world,
the world any way you want.
All people are ever doing is playing
power games based on their identity and
there's going to be no crosstalk between
the power hierarchies.
It's not even allowed.
That's why they don't engage in dialogue
c just to talk to like let's say if
you're a.
If you're a postmodernist just to have a
discussion with someone like you,
you know,
a heterosexual,
what do they call the CIS gendered male
of power,
you know,
and,
and white to boot.
It's like that's,
that's an evil act in and of itself
because all you're doing by engaging in
dialogue with that person is validating
their,
their power game.
That's all you see and this isn't,
this isn't,
this is no aberration,
that these people don't engage in
dialogue,
that it's no aberration.
It's built right into the philosophical
system.
They regard the idea of the idea that if
you're in one power group and I'm in
another,
the idea that we can step out of that
group,
engage in a dialogue,
have our worlds meat and produce some
sort of understanding of some sort of
negotiated understanding.
No,
that's part of your,
your oppressive patriarchal game.
That idea,
that whole idea is part of your game,
so if I even engage in the dialogue,
I'm playing your game,
you win.
It's a complete as complete.
People don't understand that
postmodernism is a complete assault on
two things.
One is it's an assault on the
metaphysical substrate of our culture
and I would say that the metaphysical
substrate looks something like a
religious substrate,
so it's a direct assault on that,
and the second thing it's an assault on
is everything that's been established
since the enlightenment,
rationality,
empiricism,
science,
everything,
clarity of mind,
dialogue,
the idea of the individual,
all of that is,
is not only you'd see,
it's not only that it's up for grabs,
that's not the thing.
It's to be destroyed.
That's the goal,
to be destroyed.
Just like the Communists wanted,
you know,
one,
the revolution to destroy the capitalist
system.
It's the same thing.
These people now you might say,
well,
because every social justice warrior
activist know this,
it's like,
well,
no,
of course not.
It's not.
Not Anymore than any.
Every Muslim knows the entire Muslim
doctrine or Islamic doctrine or every
Christian knows the entire Christian
doctrine.
You know,
it's fragmented among people,
but then when you bring them together,
the fragments unite and the entire
philosophy acts itself out,
so you don't think that this is a
nefarious plot by a few well planned out
individuals that have some sort of an
agenda that they're going to promote
this ideology because they and they
understand what they're doing.
You feel like it's what you're saying,
that there's a bunch of different
factions,
bunch of,
bunch of different parts to this,
and it could be a lot of it is that
people feel disenfranchised socially.
They,
they are empowered by their positions in
universities and by these insulated
environments and groups,
they're intoxicated by the power that
they have over young people and shaping
their minds and,
and,
and imposing their ideologies.
They receive feedback from these kids.
It builds up,
everything strengthens.
They shore up the walls around them and
they pushed this forward and then when
they have something like this speech
that you gave at mcmasters and they get
to actually act,
it unites them.
That unites them and this is what you're
getting from this glazed eye,
you know?
Yeah,
yeah.
Well,
well it's,
it's as if it's like Richard Dawkins
idea of meme.
You know,
if you imagine that in your,
in your neuro neural structure,
whatever ideas that you're manifesting
are represented neuron by neuron.
Let's say it's a web of neurons,
not any one neuron has the entire idea
set.
This is obviously an oversimplification,
but you get the point.
There's a network from which the idea
emerges.
Well,
the meme idea is is that an idea can
rest upon multiple individuals as if
each individual is a neuron,
and so I mean there are people who are
more or less fully informed as to the
nature of postmodern doctrine and
they're pushing it forward.
Consciously and unconsciously.
There are consciously pushing it forward
and acting it out,
and so there are individuals who are
more representative of the entire set of
ideas and individuals who are less
representative,
but if you get them together in a group,
the thing that animates them and unites
them is the common set of ideas and
those ideas were produced by the
postmodern French intellectuals in the,
in the mid seventies,
roughly speaking,
shocked Derrida,
Michel Foucault.
Foucault was the person who famously
pronounced that psychiatric diagnostic
categories were primarily social in
origin rather than biological.
And you know,
I read,
flew close work pink.
It was madness and civilization where
he,
he advanced that particular doctrine.
You can actually read Fuko unlike
Derrida and uh,
but I just found what he was writing
obvious.
It's,
I knew from my clinical training that
psychiatric categories have a heavy
sociological construction,
partly because psychiatry is into
science.
Medicine isn't a science,
it's an applied science.
Those aren't the same thing at all.
And you know,
a pure science is pure science that
deals with scientific categories like
Adams,
but an applied science.
Well,
it's a compromise between all sorts of
different things and mental illnesses
themselves are shaped by the social
environment.
Even though often they have a biological
route,
the way they manifest themselves as
clearly shaped by society and language.
I didn't find his work the least bit
surprising.
I thought.
Well really,
I mean everyone who's a sophisticated
medical professional psychiatrist,
psychologist,
everyone knows that.
It's like,
I mean,
there's a book called discovery of the
unconscious by a guy named Henri
Ellenberger,
Jay that was written in the believe in
the sixties,
great book on history of psychoanalysis
and like he covers the shift and
diagnostic categories across time.
It's self evident.
So anyways,
there's all these French postmodernists.
They were all marxists.
Most of them were student
revolutionaries in France in the late 19
sixties before that all fell apart and
they did two things.
They pulled out this frame problem,
issue the issue of multiple
interpretations and said,
well,
there's nothing that's canonical.
There's no overarching narrative,
there's no real interpretation.
And I already said why that's wrong.
And then the other thing they said was
they did the slight of hand.
So instead of the working class against
the verge was easy.
It was,
it was race against race or gender
against gender.
Unbelievably divisive.
It's all they believe in his identity.
There's no individual man that's gone
with postmodernism.
This isn't an accident.
All of this stuff,
it's not random.
It's driven by these ideas,
like ideas are always at war always,
and we're in a war between these ideas.
I mean,
Marxism we already know is tremendously
powerful doctrine and this is its newest
manifestation.
What is the motivation behind the
individuals that are at the heart of
this movement?
Well,
I would say that the motivations are as
complex as as human motivations are in
general,
but they seem to have solidified into a
movement,
right?
Well,
I think the dangerous part of it is that
the kind of.
It's almost like a scapegoat mentality.
It's almost like psychoanalytic
projection.
That's another way of thinking about it.
So like one of the things that I've come
to learn and one of the things I talk
about a lot is that the battle between
good and evil,
so to speak,
isn't between states and it's not
between the individuals precisely.
Although it manifests itself at those
levels.
It's an internal battle,
a moral battle that happens inside
people.
And so people have a broad capacity for
malevolence and for and for benevolence,
and that's a terrible war for people and
it's a terrible thing to understand and
realize.
In fact,
often when people realize their capacity
for malevolence,
if they're not prepared for it,
they develop posttraumatic stress
disorder.
So that happens to soldiers and
battlefields.
So they go out,
they're innocent guys,
you know,
naive guys,
young guys,
and they go out onto a battlefield and
they get put in a really stressful
situation and you know,
they,
they step outside themselves and they do
something unbelievably vicious and
brutal and then they're broken.
They can't take that manifestation of
themself and put it with like Iowa Corn
Fed,
you know,
nice guy and no wonder because one is
like a flesh eating chimp chimpanzee on
a war rampage.
And the other is,
you know,
a relatively well brought up and polite
farm boy from the middle of the United
States.
It's like how in the world you're going
to put those two things together while
you can't.
That's posttraumatic stress disorder.
And to treat that,
my experience with posttraumatic stress
disorder is that you have to teach
people a philosophy of evil,
of good and evil,
because otherwise they can't recover.
And I've had.
I've had,
by the way,
in the last four months,
I've had two letters from people from
soldiers with ptsd and I met to
personally who said that watching my
lectures had had brought them back
together because they couldn't
understand how they had become before
looking,
looking deeply at,
at the,
at their malevolence now.
So I would say with regards to this
movement,
this postmodern movement,
the malevolent aspect of it,
there's.
There's a couple of them.
One,
it's unbelievably authoritarian.
Can I got a letter today from a
university student in Italy,
I don't know what university,
but she'd been having kind of a flame
war on facebook with a,
with a social justice warrior.
And at the end she recommended that this
particular social justice warrior seek
out a local mental health counseling
unit and put a link to it in the
exchange.
And then she got a letter from the
university.
I guess the other person that sjw type
turned her in,
but she got a letter from the university
saying that that violated university
policy and constituted harassment and
that she should seriously consider
retracting it and that future employees,
employers might be looking at what she
posted and it was inappropriate to put
that on a public site and it's like,
I thought,
wow,
if.
How could you be so clueless as a,
as a administrator say to think that
your monitoring of your students'
private utterances,
you're monitoring it at an institutional
level and your intervention and threat
at an institutional level is less
dangerous than lending to students,
you know,
troll each other on,
on a,
on a public social forum.
It's just,
I just,
I don't know what to think about it.
It's just unbelievable.
It happened and it's happening all over
the place.
This sort of thing.
And so there's the authoritarian element
to it,
which is a hatred of.
I think it's a hatred of competence
because competence produces hierarchies
that aren't based on power.
I think it's a hatred of clear
intellect,
hatred of clear interlink.
How so?
What do you mean when you say clear,
but you have a clear intellect as far as
I'm concerned?
I think that's why you're so popular is
because you pay attention and say what
you see and you're not too concerned
about doing anything other than that.
I mean,
yeah,
of course you have an agenda because
everyone has an agenda.
You can't help but have an agenda if
you're alive,
but you can temper the agenda like you
can be clued in enough to try to listen
and learn and watch and pay attention to
what your own senses are telling you and
try to articulate that and that's what
the logos is technically and the reason
I'm bringing this up is because Jacques
Derrida described Western culture in a
famous phrase.
He described it as
fallow fell,
logocentric,
p h a l logo l o g o centric fell logo
centric and it needs to be brought down
while the Phallus part.
That's male.
The logo part.
That's logos.
Now that's partly logic because the
board logic comes from the word logos,
but logos is a deep mate.
Much,
much older concept and logic like logos
is.
It's essentially a theological concept
and that's where things get complicated,
but you could describe it as a,
as the manifestation of truth in speech
and the postmodernist.
They don't like
any of that.
So foul logo center,
some Legos.
It would be the ultimate mansplaining.
Yes,
exactly.
Yes.
Like any man who expresses a or tries to
correct a woman in any way becomes a man
claiming to correct anything in any way.
Particularly with you where the Ted
Cruz,
Sally Yates testimony that's been going
on in America.
Pretty fascinating because.
No,
I'm not aware of that.
I saw an example of that in Australia
and our congressional debate where a guy
was accused of mansplaining by one of
his colleagues and really tore a strip
off her quite nicely.
So what's happening in the states?
He will.
Yates has just been pretty brilliant.
She was fired by the trump
administration because she rejected this
idea of um,
what was the,
uh,
the very specific things about
restricting immigration,
about shutting down a different people
that are trying to come into the United
States.
And she had this debate with Ted Cruz
where she just brilliantly shut him down
with her knowledge of the Constitution
and knowledge of what is and what is not
legal or should or should not be allowed
to happen.
And she was fired for it and he was
grilling her and his,
you know,
he's a very smart guy,
ted Cruz.
Although I don't agree with him and I
agree more with her.
The wait was going down.
This debate was described as
mansplaining because it was a man
talking to a woman.
It's just a recent example.
I also read about something like that
with regards to the Supreme Court
because somebody did an analysis showing
that the female Supreme Court justices
spoke less than the male supreme court
justices immediately attributed that to
sexism because you know,
how pressed female Supreme Court
justices are.
So,
um,
the,
the still want to get back to this,
that the hatred or the dislike of clear
thinking.
Yup.
Do you think that this comes from people
that,
I'm not even sure I completely wrapped
my head around this,
but do you think this is from someone
with a.
They understand that their logic is
muddy.
They understand that they're imposing of
this muddy logic is illogical in some
sort of a way.
They feel it.
They feel it,
feel it rather than think it.
I mean,
that's the other thing is that there
isn't a lot of clear thinking on the
side of the social justice types because
a lot of what they're doing is real
emotional,
emotional level.
Yeah.
Well,
they're the best personality predictor
of,
of a politically correct belief because
we've done this study,
although it's not published yet,
is trait agreeableness,
agreeableness.
I would say the best way to think about
it is that it's the maternal dimension.
That's an oversimplification,
but not much of one.
Um,
and so anybody that the maternal
viewpoint,
it's something like anybody who's part
of my ingroup is an infant in trouble
and anyone who's outside of it is a
predatory snake or something like that.
And so you're seeing that manifest
itself in a political doctrine.
Well,
you clearly seeing that today with
what's going on with these,
like,
like say the Berkeley Milo rally where
people who are on the left,
who you would think of as being pro
woman pro,
uh,
you know,
antiviolence are more than capable of
committing violence against women who
support trump because then they
categorize them as Nazis and we're
supposed to punch Nazis and I mean
there's been a bunch of instances where
you've seen video footage of people
getting pepper sprayed and hit with
sticks because they were wearing the
wrong,
you know,
they're wearing or it wasn't even a make
America great again hat.
It was actually,
uh,
make bitcoin great again.
Hap.
There's a very famous video of a girl
getting pepper sprayed.
Yeah,
I think I've seen that one fucking crazy
began by the left and by people who are
supposed to be,
you know,
quote unquote progressive and people
were supposed to be pro women's rights,
you know,
anti violence against women,
anti domestic violence,
but yet they have no problem doing it to
this other person because this person
becomes the other because they're on the
other side.
Yeah.
Well,
this I was talking about this line
between good and evil runs down people's
hearts.
It's,
well,
it's,
it's a terrible fault line and it can be
shocking to see that it's the case and
so it's much more convenient for people
to divide the world into the righteous
and the and the damned let's say,
and then to to persecute the damned
well,
it's.
It's convenient too because you whatever
resentment and hatred and bitterness you
have in your heart and you have plenty
of that.
Generally speaking,
if you're a social justice type because
you regard yourself as oppressed and
then like that's a great starting point
for resentment and hatred,
right?
To be,
to be a victim.
We know that that one of the precursors
to genocide,
and I'm not saying at all that were near
that state,
I'm not saying that,
but one of the precursors to genocide in
a genocidal state or in a pre genocidal
state is the.
The acceptance of victim status by the
eventual perpetrators.
Because the idea as well,
like we're innocent,
we're being persecuted now.
Those people are going to get us.
So eventually that becomes,
well,
we'll get them and it gives you have a
target for all your resentment and your
hatred and it's a justifiable moral
target and so all the parts of yourself
that you don't recognize as contributing
to whatever problem you think you know
now pollutes the world.
You can ignore all that.
You're on the side of the good.
There's no moral effort required and
then you have someone to conveniently
hate and hit and hurt and all the wild.
You can look at yourself in the mirror
and say,
I'm,
I'm on the side of the good.
I'm just punching Nazis.
Right,
right.
What is.
They're hitting them with bike locks.
You know,
while you dart out behind a woman who's
conveniently standing in front of you,
is there an evolutionary origin for what
we were talking about in regards to a
soldier being able to commit these
horrible atrocities in the name of war
to the these people that are able to
look at someone who has a different
ideology as the other and attack them as
almost like a sub human is.
Zero is some sort of an evolutionary
origin for this disassociative sort of
thinking and behavior that some people
seem to.
I mean it seems like a very common thing
throughout history.
Sure.
Anything that isn't part of your
dominance hierarchies?
A snake.
It's that.
And it actually makes sense from an
evolutionary perspective.
I mean,
first of all,
we are tribal primates,
right?
And on our optimal group size seems to
be something like 250.
We can keep track of a boat that many
social relationships.
And that's,
that's also also number.
That's right,
exactly.
And that's correlated with brain size,
right?
So all right.
And so you might say,
well why that size?
And then you might say,
well hierarchy has to be optimized for
two functions in one is what you want to
be able to climb the damn thing.
So if it's really,
really big,
the probability that you're going to
climb it is really low and if it's too
small,
well who cares if you climate?
So yeah,
you want it somewhere that let's go big
enough to climb and powerful enough to
make the climb worthwhile.
And so and so there's some optimization
there now,
so you might think of everything within
that hierarchy as explored territory.
And the reason for that is that explored
territory is where when you do
something,
you get what you want.
So,
so think about the conditions under
which the limits of your knowledge
manifest themselves.
I mean,
there's also sorts of things you don't
know,
you know,
a trillion things,
but you're not sitting there like
torturing yourself to death because
there's a trillion things you don't
know.
But then if you go out in the world and
you act something out and the outcome
isn't what you desired,
then that registers an error.
So let's say you're at a party and you
tell a joke and no one laughs.
Well,
the party you see,
think about what happens to the space
around the party.
When you tell the joke the second before
you tell the joke,
you're in one place and the second after
when there's an awkward silence and
everybody's
looking embarrassed,
you are no longer in the same place.
You've stepped outside the protective
embrace of,
of that particular hierarchy.
And you've made yourself an alien and
the thing that people use to process the
alien is the is the snake detector,
the serpent detector,
the dragon detector,
and it's always been that way because
anything that's out side,
the hierarchy is a threat.
Any stranger,
any strange idea,
any,
any animal manifestation,
any noise,
any spirit,
it's an.
It's a,
it's a threat to the integrity of the
dominance hierarchy and in many,
many ways.
So for example,
it's deeply rooted because that was your
question.
What's the evolutionary basis?
There's a great paper published in a
journal called plause,
one p l o s one about five or six years
ago looking at something absolutely
terrifying in my estimation,
which was there's this,
there's this idea that part of what
motivates the authoritarian end of
political conservatism.
So let's say the right wing fascist end
is associated not with fear but with
disgust.
Disgust is an entirely different
emotion.
And so these researchers did this
fascinating study where they went to a
number of different countries and also
looked at states within the same country
looking at the relationship between the
prevalence of infectious disease and
authoritarian attitudes at the
individual level.
The higher the infectious disease rate,
the more authoritarian,
the political views,
and,
and the correlation was really high.
It wasn't like point one,
it was point seven.
It's one of the highest correlations
between two phenomena I've ever seen in
the social studies sciences.
And you might say,
well,
why?
Well here's one reason I said that.
The strange idea and the stranger and
the pathogen,
let's say,
are all the same thing.
Well,
it's all because they're external
threats to the structure,
the dominance hierarchy.
You know,
when they.
When the Spaniards came to the new
world,
95 percent of the natives died.
They died from smallpox.
They died from measles,
they died from mumps.
They died from chicken pox because you
don't know what the hell is coming at
you.
When you let something new inside the
dominance hierarchy,
whether it's an idea or a disease or a
virus.
I think that was Laurie.
No,
that was a heroin addict author.
Boros Boros.
Yeah.
That was his phrase.
Laurie Anderson made a nice video about
that.
Words are a virus and so we respond to
them with the same circuitry that we use
to detect pathogens and I'll tell you
something even more frightening when we
were working this out because it's
associated with this trait called
orderliness,
which is actually a good predictor of,
of right wing political belief.
I went back and looked at Hitler's table
talk.
It's a book,
Hitler's table talk,
and he wrote that it was derived from
notes that were taken by his secretary's
between 1939 and 1942 when he was eating
dinner and spontaneously expounding on
the structure of reality.
He was very open.
Hitler,
very creative person,
but also extremely orderly.
Um,
and I at the metaphors that he was using
to describe the Jews and the Gypsies and
all the other people that he burned and
destroyed.
And it was all pathogen.
It's all pathogen metaphor.
The aryan race is a body.
It's a pure body.
The blood is pure,
that Jews are rats or insects or or lice
or disease and so are the Gypsies and
everyone else and they need to be
eradicated in burned out essentially.
Here's something even more frightening.
So when,
when Hitler,
when Hitler took over Germany,
he was kind of a public health freak and
he will also washed his hands a lot
every day and he was also a worshiper of
willpower,
so he was a really orderly guy and he
started this public health campaign in
Germany and he put together these vans
that would go around like screening
people for tuberculosis,
which you know,
is a perfectly fine idea,
but then they started a beautification
program of the factories because he
didn't like how messy the factories were
in Germany.
So we had people clean them up,
sweep them out and plant flowers out
front and,
and fumigate them for rats and insects,
right?
Parasites.
Oh.
And the Jews were always compared to
rats and insects as well.
They used cycle on b to do the
insecticide.
Well,
it's like long b.
That was the gas that was used in the,
in the death camps.
So it went like pathogen insect rats
that it went into the silence,
you know,
so.
So that people who were mentally
deficient,
they were like parasites and rats,
and then it was Jews and Gypsies and
parasites and rats.
They were using Xy,
Colombian nods,
icon a I,
I believe,
they were using cycle and be,
I don't know,
I know that the gas was Zike lawn or
there is icon a was the gas that was
formulated with a very extreme smell so
that people would smell it and know
because it was extremely toxic Zike on
be.
It all came from Fritz Harbor Harbor was
the guy created the harbor method of
extracting nitrogen from the oxygen that
we use for fertilizer today.
Harbor created Xy clon a and made it
extremely toxic smelling so that you
would know to avoid it Zyklon B,
that that whatever element was removed
from the area so that it would be used
in gas chambers.
They'd have no idea that they're being
gassed proper.
Who was a Jew,
ironically did not know that his Zyklon
a was eventually going to be used on his
own.
Yeah.
Well,
I,
I suspect they probably use cycle on a
locations,
you know,
but,
but the thing is,
is that,
well,
so you know,
you said what's the biological basis and
the biological basis is that like we're
basically wired in some sense also to,
to for the domain of order or the domain
of chaos.
That's another way of thinking about it.
The domain of order,
once again is where you are when what
you're doing is working because see,
because our,
our environment isn't just natural.
It's also social.
So not only do you have to deal with the
vagaries of the natural world properly
so that it gives you what you are aiming
at.
That's how you know if you're right,
it gives you what aiming at but you have
to do it in a way that other people
approve of and support.
And it's a very tight constraint.
We talked about that as a constraint on
the interpretation of the world,
but then now and then something happens
to disrupt that stability.
So that's like the white circle.
That's the black circle in the white
serpent,
in the Yin Yang symbol.
You know,
how the,
how the white one that's order,
the white one has a black.in
it nets because chaos can come pouring
through into order at any moment and you
have a circuit that detects that and
that's the same circuit that detects
snakes or predators and that obviously
why wouldn't it be,
you know,
an intruding force and intruding forest
has to be responded to right now.
So there's a need for a demand
instantaneous response to sandy because
most,
like you were saying,
of those kids,
like almost a unhuman or disassociative
sort of,
uh,
the ability to act almost as if like,
like something other than a person with
a humanization.
Right.
And the Deq.
The thing is,
is another thing that's so funny is that
we think that the natural response to
looking at a human being is
humanization.
And that isn't right.
Like the default person in some sense
isn't human.
The default member of your tribe is
human.
I mean,
most tribes around the world,
the name for their tribe is the people
implying that there are the people and
all those other things out there are
barbarians right there.
There are forces of chaos are the
stranger,
they bring disease in trouble.
Now,
I don't want to be too bleak about it
because this is the basic debate between
conservatives and liberals to some
degree is the conservatives take the
stranger equals pathogen route more
frequently and they're less attracted to
the idea of the free of or they work
conventionally.
That trade with a foreigner has benefits
that outweigh the risks.
And generally speaking,
liberals have the opposite attitude.
So,
but that's because those two things are
both true.
One is that,
man,
it's really useful to trade with
strangers because they have all sorts of
cool things you don't have but be,
well,
it might be real dangerous because you
don't know what those things are
infected with.
Like realistically speaking,
let's say.
But then also metaphorically speaking,
here's an example of how,
how,
uh,
an object can be a virus.
I think about the automobile,
like if you wanted to introduce
something into a communist country that
screamed the paramount status of the
individual,
you couldn't possibly create something
that broadcast that more clearly than a
car.
Right?
The car is driven by one person.
The person is completely autonomous,
are completely sealed off.
They don't need any state support or
sanctioned whatsoever to move around in
the car.
It's like if you want to do in.
If you wanted to rescue the communists
from their collective pathology,
the best thing to do would be to
parachute in automobiles because the
automobile just screams individual
autonomy and so when you,
when you get a an artifact from a
foreigner,
you don't know what that's contaminated
with,
let's put it that way.
And so we have a circuit for dealing
with that and it's a,
it's a,
it's the thing that associates the
foreigner with the force that eats the
sun when it sets at night.
That's the most archaic way of thinking
about it,
but it's the snake or the Predator.
So,
and what do you do with a snake or a
predator?
Man,
you burn it,
you kill it,
you crush it.
It's like there's a.
there's a destructive force that comes
along with it with that.
That's absolutely.
Well,
it's morally righteous because yeah,
you know,
if it's a poisonous snake and it's
threatening the village,
obviously you kill it and then you're
celebrated for it.
So in a sense the same dehumanizing
force that allows people to act that way
in war also allows people to
disassociate between anyone who doesn't
agree with their ideology in a school
setting,
in a university like what happened at
Mclean.
Yeah.
That's why.
That's why I don't like it ecologies
because the ideology does divides the
world into those safely ensconced within
our dominance hierarchy and serpents.
And so that's dangerous.
And,
and the reason that,
that this doctrine that I described
about the line between good and evil
running down the individual's heart.
I mean I got that particular line mostly
from Alexander Solzhenitsyn,
but it's also a,
it's a,
it's an idea that's been developed
intensively in the West for thousands
and thousands of years.
Maybe it's been developed since far
before we.
We invented the stories in genesis
because of course the serpent see in
genesis,
of course genesis is like a paradise,
right,
so you can think about it as a well
functioning hierarchy.
It's also a balance between chaos and
order.
It's got walls and it's a garden,
so but there's a snake that pops his
head in and that's the same as that.
As I said,
that black dot inside the white serpent
in the union symbol,
it's that no matter how,
doesn't matter how perfect the the
environment is set up,
something that doesn't fit is going to
make its way inside.
It's one of the oldest stories of of
mankind,
and you see the thing that makes itself
manifest inside in the genesis story is
a snake.
Now that snake turns out to be Satan,
which is like,
how the hell does that happen?
It's a snake.
Like,
what?
Where does that come from?
It's not actually in the biblical
writings to any degree.
It's part of the surrounding mythology.
Well,
it's partly because people started to
figure out that the worst snake wasn't a
snake.
The worst snake was the snake that was
inside a person because a malevolent
person is way more of a threat than just
a snake,
like a snake wants to bite unit,
wants to eat you and all of that,
and and they were hell on are extremely
primordial ancestors,
but we're.
The human race has been trying to figure
out where the threat is forever.
Well,
first of all,
it was external,
right?
It was all external.
It was the snake.
It was the barbarian,
but then it got localized to some degree
inside the individual.
It's like that's a bad person.
That person has a snake in them,
and then the idea kind of came out.
This is so cool.
The idea is that while the snake that's
inside bad person a and the snake that's
inside bad person b is somehow the same.
So that's where the idea of an
articulated morality starts to come from
is there's an equivalence of evil across
individuals.
So then the idea of evil itself starts
to become abstracted to at the same time
that the idea of good does well,
evil gets associated with Satan and
Satan gets associated with the snake.
It's,
it's mind boggling.
I mean,
these are how these chimps,
for Christ's sake,
you know,
it took us a long time to develop up,
say an ideal,
just to say the word.
An ideal implies a counter ideal say,
well,
those things were embodied way before
they were ideas and after they were
embodied,
first,
not as bad,
but as a bad thing or a bad person,
bad had to be extracted out of that.
And even that was extracted as a drama
first.
You know,
it's like the bad guy in a movie.
He isn't a bad guy,
he's a composite bad guy.
You know,
he,
he's,
he's a literary bad guy and the good guy
isn't just a good guy.
He's a literary good guy.
He's a hero.
He's got way more heroic attributes than
the typical person.
And that's where abstract ideas are
born.
So anyways,
back to your question,
the use,
you said,
um,
what's the evolutionary basis for that
sort of dissociative behavior and
thinking?
Yeah,
so I'm afraid that that was a big rabbit
hole,
man.
No,
it's a great rabbit hole and it makes a
whole lot of sense that there's an
actual.
And I knew you probably knew this,
which is why I asked you that knew you
had an answer rather that there is some
sort of an evolutionary basis for that
sort of be that ability that people have
to look at someone as the other,
you bet.
Well also how the hell are you going to
respond in war if you don't have that,
right?
Like that was always an issue with
people with invading tribes and like you
said,
with other external threats,
whether it was animals or insects or
snakes or anything,
they could kill you.
Yeah.
Well I mean in,
in,
in a primordial situation,
I mean guys are in warrior mode a good
part of the time and modern people don't
even know what that's like.
That's why they go out and they go into
warrior mode and they get post traumatic
stress disorder because it's so unlike
the way they configure themselves that,
that they can't even,
they can't even bridged the gap between
the two identities and for,
um,
just for sake of clarity,
I think for some folks,
posttraumatic stress disorder is
actually come from,
not just that,
but also from the threat
of being attacked from what I
understand,
people like special ops people,
people like rangers and Navy seals and
the like are less likely to develop
posttraumatic stress disorder because
they're acting versus reacting that
whereas people that are on that are
going on like,
um,
patrol and then they get blown up.
Like those people apparently have a far
more likely issue with posttraumatic
stress disorder because they're
constantly worried about these external
threats.
And then they,
when they come back to civilization,
they have a very difficult time getting
back to baseline.
Yeah.
They're in prey mode.
Yes.
Very serious way.
Yeah.
So it's not just acting,
but it's also reacting that the reacting
issue sometimes is even more problematic
for the individual than the acting mode.
Yeah.
Well there's,
there's,
there's a funny dichotomy there because
very frequently if you're going to
encounter a stress,
it's best to do it voluntarily because
you use a whole different circuit used
the approach circuit.
And so,
I mean that sounds paradoxical what you
just said because I said that,
you know,
people often observe themselves doing
something to get posttraumatic stress
disorder and then you said,
well yeah,
but if people act they're less likely
to.
But that's part of a more general
phenomenon,
which is that in the face of a stressor,
you're,
you're better off cycle physiologically
to act voluntarily.
It's either you're either going to be
the thing that advances on the,
on the anomaly or its prey.
Now that's,
that's roughly the way to think about it
and to be a prey animal is a terrible
thing because it's doom.
It's paralysis.
Like literally speaking.
It's like in the Harry Potter series
with the basketball is Greg,
you look at the basilisk and it turns
you to stone.
Well,
why?
because that's what happens to a prey
animal when a horrible Predator looks at
it,
it's frozen.
It's turned into stone.
That's Medusa with all her snakes,
right?
She looks at you,
man.
Mother Nature looks at you.
The the like the devouring part of
Mother Nature opens her eye on you.
It's like you're paralyzed.
That's an old,
old story.
That is
really interesting thing that I never
considered that my medusa does have this
head of snakes and she looks at you,
she turns you into stone and that is the
biggest issue with people.
It's not fight or flight.
People think it's fight or flight.
It's fight,
flight or freeze.
The freeze thing is very common with
people and I've seen it.
I've seen it with people that just.
They don't know what to do when they're
in a stressful situation and instead of
reacting,
they freak out.
Yup,
Yup.
They freak out or they freeze so they
just lock.
Well,
you can see that if we go back to that
example of say someone tells a joke,
maybe they're kind of socially anxious
and they finally managed to mumble out a
joke and it falls flat.
It's like to freeze.
The interface of that is very common
reaction.
You know the personal freeze.
Then often they'll break into tears and
run so well.
If they're socially anxious,
that's exactly what's happened because
they've now they also know that they've
been turned into a Predator,
let's say a snake Predator by the whole
community and that's very shaming and so
that,
that is dumped on top of them.
I mean that's socially anxious.
People are afraid of that all the time,
that they're going to be regarded by the
group as an outcast.
Pariah.
Right,
and it,
it's very hard on people and the
paranoid amongst them are always
thinking that people are talking about
them and trying to make them the other.
Right,
right.
Yes.
A very uncomfortable state of mind.
Yeah.
This is a very.
I think this is a very important subject
and explaining it this way.
I think for the openminded,
whoever is willing to listen to this,
who maybe might have opposed some of
your ideas before,
I think they'll get a better
understanding of what's really dangerous
about this lack of dialogue and this
lack of engaging in this shutting you
out and making you the other as it were.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean it's what postmodernism is
fundamentally concerned about.
They don't believe there's any other way
of operating in the world in that you
see in,
and this is.
This is one of the things that I think
Western civilization has contributed so
brilliantly to,
to the expansion of knowledge and the
world is,
well,
what's the.
What's the cure for the inadequacies of
the group?
While you might say it's the perfect
state,
so one of the ways I'm going to do a
series of lectures on the Bible starting
May 16th and for reasons that I outlined
to some degree when I was talking about
genesis a little bit earlier,
but in the old testament for example,
the Israelites are always trying to make
their peace with God so they're trying
to live in the world without getting
walloped constantly by natural events
and by you know,
invading forces and which they attribute
to God's will.
Yes,
yes.
Whatever's beyond their understanding.
In some sense they're more sophisticated
than merely this,
but whatever's beyond their
understanding,
but they're kind of conceptualizing
being as such and trying to figure out
how to deal with it and one of the
hypothesis they come up with is
something like,
well,
you can bargain with it and the thing is
you can.
That's one of the things that's so cool
and partly the reason you can bargain
with reality is because the reality that
you encounter as you move forward in
time is partly the world,
but partly the abstract social system.
And so you can bargain with the future
abstract social system all the time.
You do that every time you make a
promise,
you do it every time you sacrifice one
thing for another.
So you forego an impulsive temptation
and that gives you a moral claim that
you can redeem in the future that
happens,
all that.
That's what money is for God's sake.
And we discovered the future at some
point,
as I said,
we were chimpanzees.
At one point,
we discovered the future.
Then we discovered that you could
bargain with the future as if it was a
person that's amazing.
It's amazing.
And that's partly where the idea of God
as a personality came from.
I should flip that,
that idea that you could bargain with
the future came out of the idea that God
was a personality because the God as a
personality idea came first.
But it was,
uh,
it was,
it was a developmental stage on the way
to even being able to say the future.
You know,
we,
we have no idea how to say,
like a 6 million year path from
chimpanzee to,
to self aware human being.
You know,
and we don't,
we have no idea where these unbelievably
sophisticated ideas that we have come
from,
like the idea of sacrifice.
Do you know how much blood was spilled
before human beings were able to
sacrifice abstractly instead of killing
something?
We had to act out.
God enjoys you killing something because
he's happy with the blood.
We had to act that out for God who
knows?
Twenty thousand years,
100,000
years before we got anywhere near the
idea that you could do that abstractly.
So when I look at these old stories,
I look at them like an evolutionary
biologist.
Now I'm not trying to reduce them in any
way because what we don't understand
about evolution that could make a very
thick book.
And there's other strange things about
religious phenomenology that we don't
have a clue about.
You know,
like the fact that the drugs often
called entheogens.
Psychedelics can reliably produce
mystical experiences like no one has any
idea what to make of that.
You can just discounted.
It's like,
yeah,
well they're drugs.
Yeah,
sure.
People been using the things for who
knows,
50,000
years.
One hundred and 50,000
years,
they might be the source of all our
religious ideas.
I don't.
I'm not saying that they are,
but they could well be and so why do we
have a capacity for mystical experience?
Who knows it?
It's it's associated with a sense of
awe.
It's associated with the same feeling
that you get when you listen to
particularly dramatic music or when or
when something moves you deeply and you
know the hair on the back of your neck
stands up.
You know what that is?
That's Pilau erection.
That's the same thing that happens to a
cat when it looks at a particularly big
dog.
It's all you feel that when there's a
swell of music off,
you're the hair stands up on the back of
your neck.
It's like you pop up just like a cat
except like a bald cat.
So what do you make of this idea that,
well,
not the idea,
but the reality that these entheogens
closely mimic human neurochemistry,
know what they do.
There's absolutely no doubt about it.
What do you think the reason for that
is?
Well,
a part of the reason is,
is that we share an evolutionary pathway
with all these things that we eat,
plants and fungi,
and you know,
look,
we're,
we're linked evolutionarily to every
form of life on the planet,
you know,
and,
and like Serotonin in lobsters has the
same effect on lobsters as it does on
human being.
So if you up their serotonin levels
artificially,
the lobster gets,
stands up more erect and stronger and as
much more willing to fight.
And if you decrease the serotonin in the
lobsters,
nervous system,
then it gets all depressed and runs away
and hides things.
Think about that.
I mean,
we,
we split off from lobster about 350
million years ago and still live in
dominance hierarchies.
That's how old the dominance hierarchy
is.
There's plan that's older than trees.
It's older than flowers.
It's permanent,
right?
We've evolved for the hierarchy and in
the spirit of the hierarchy,
that's,
that's the Old Testament God,
that's at least part of it,
the spirit of the hierarchy.
So these things are,
while they're mind boggling to me,
which is partly why I'm investigating
them,
but all of our wiring is conditional on
that.
So what I mean women use the dominance
hierarchy to select mates.
So it's so strange because you know,
people think of evolution from a natural
selection perspective almost always,
but sexual selection plays a huge role.
So here all layout something wild for
you.
Okay?
So we know that you have twice as many
female ancestors as male ancestors.
Now people have a hard time with that,
but you could imagine that roughly
speaking,
that would happen if every single woman
had one baby and only every second man
fathered a child.
So for men it would be,
you either have two kids are zero.
Well,
that's basically what it is on average
across type.
If you're a man,
you have two children,
maybe with two different women or zero.
If you're a woman,
everyone has one.
That's how it averages out.
So there's more disparity of success
among men.
And that's very common in the animal
kingdom by the way.
Now the question is how to women select
their mates?
Now,
unlike female chimps,
female humans are choosy maters.
Female chimps will meet with any chimp.
They go into heat,
they'll meet with any chimp.
The dominant males are more likely to
mate with them,
but that's because they chase away the
subordinates.
It's not because the females exercise
choice,
human females exercise choice,
and that's one of the things that
differentiated us from chimpanzees,
but how do they do it?
Well,
they look at the male dominance
hierarchy and that's where the men are
competing.
Now you could say they're competing for
power,
but that's pretty corrupt way of looking
at it like they're competing for,
let's say influence.
They're competing for leadership and so
in some sense the people at the top of
the hierarchy,
if they're men,
are elected by the other band.
Now I know there was brutes and there's
predators and all of that,
but I'm talking on average across time.
It's like the men organized themselves
and there are influential men that rise
to the top and the women take them.
Now we think about that.
What that means is that over the
millions of years that a dominance
hierarchy with those properties existed.
So let's say since we split from chimps,
let's say that 6 million years,
that means that the male dominance
hierarchy is the environment that pushes
the mating mail to the top.
So that means the mail that's most
likely to take precedence in the dorm in
the male dominance hierarchy is the one
most likely to leave a genetic
contribution.
So that means that the male dominance
hierarchies,
a selection mechanism mediated by the
female.
So what that means is that as we've
moved forward through 6 million years of
time,
men have become more and more well
adopted,
not only to the presence of the male
dominance hierarchy,
but to the ability to move up it.
And that's the central spirit.
You could say in some sense,
that's the central spirit of the
individual.
The individual is the thing that can
move up.
Dominance hierarchies.
It's the thing that's at the top.
It's the eye at the top of the pyramid
and it's been selected for.
And then what's happened is we've
watched so we get better and better and
better for biological reasons,
culturally mediated at figuring out how
to climb across a set of dominance
hierarchy so we can leave a genetic
contribution.
That's what's happened to human beings.
Now imagine that that's happened for 6
million years.
So now imagine that.
We started to watch that because we're
curious creatures.
We're always trying to figure out who we
are.
And then as we watched that,
we started to tell stories about what
the people who could climb the
hierarchies were like those were heroes.
That's where Harold mythology came from.
And the biggest hero is the person will
go out and killed a snake.
Well,
unsurprisingly,
because that was a big hero man.
And maybe when we living in trees,
that was a hero.
So the big hero is the person who goes
out,
slays the dragon,
gets the gold,
brings it back to the community and
distributed.
He's also the person most likely to go
up the dominant Turkey.
He's the person most likely to find the
virgin,
right?
Because it's a virgin that you free from
the dragon and you get to claim her
right,
and so the dominance hierarchy is a
mechanism that selects heroes and then
breeds them.
And so then we watched that for $6,
million years.
We start to understand what it means to
be the hero.
We start to tell stories about that and
so then not only are we genetically
aiming at that with the dominance
hierarchy is a selection mechanism
mediated by female choice,
but our stories are trying to push us in
that direction.
And so then we say,
well look,
that person's admirable tell story about
him and we say this person is admirable
of cal story about him and this person
is admirable and at the same time we
talk about the people who aren't
admirable and then we start having
admirable and non admirable as
categories.
And out of that you get something like
good and evil and then you can start to
imagine the perfect person.
That would be not only.
So it would be you take 10 admirable
people in.
You pull out someone who's met admirable
and that's a hero.
That becomes a religious figure across
time that becomes a savior,
a messiah across time,
as we conceptualize what the ideal
person is and we didn't in the West.
Here's how we figured it out.
We said the ideal person,
the ideal man is the person who tells
the truth.
And what that means is that the best way
of climbing up any possible dominance
hierarchy in a way that's most stable
and most lasting.
That's,
that's the conclusion of western
culture.
Sure.
So in a sense,
psychologically,
when you talk about postmodernists and
their rejection of these classic male
structures are,
what they're doing is realizing that
they're not going to compete in the
classic as stated male hierarchy.
So they're their own
version of it.
Sure.
That's the creative element.
While we,
we,
he,
we asked earlier,
what's the motivation of these
pathological guys who are out there like
bolstering up the feminists?
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
they don't compete any other way.
They don't compete.
They figured out how to compete.
They compete as allies.
Let's say [inaudible] very sneaky.
Yeah.
Wow.
Yeah,
and that's how everybody always
describes them to when you.
I mean,
it's almost like a,
we,
I avoid doing it because I just,
it just almost feels gross to label them
like that,
but that's,
that is the way you think of male
feminists.
You think of them as sneaky.
Yeah.
And you know,
it's creepy and discriminated
discriminatory towards classic male
behaviors.
Yeah.
Well,
no wonder they haven't got a hope of
competing in that hierarchy.
Wow,
that's deep.
That is deep.
This is going to be hurtful to a lot of
people.
So a lot of people listening to this
right now,
very upset you.
You asked earlier why,
why the postmodernists don't like blunt
speech.
That's why man,
you know,
it's like the truth is something that
Burns,
it burns off deadwood and people don't
like having their dead wood burn it off
often because they're like 95 percent
deadwood and,
and I'm not being.
Believe me,
I'm not being snide about that.
It's no joke.
When you start to realize how much of
what you've constructed of yourself is
based on deception and lies,
that is a horrifying realization and it
can easily be 95 percent of you have
your things.
You say things,
you act out,
you know it's well.
You see that in Pinocchio,
which I often you discuss,
you know Pinocchio,
when he gets corrupt,
as he,
as he matures,
he first learns to lie and then he
becomes a brain jackass on pleasure
island.
It's like,
and he's threatened by the underground
authoritarians,
right?
They're going to sell them to the salt
mines.
It's like,
yeah,
that's for sure.
It's exactly right man.
So then you figure out your uh,
brain jackass and you're lying all the
time.
That's a terrible realization.
And then all that needs to be burned
away and no people don't like that.
You know?
Now you've been embattled in this
conflict for quite a long time and I've
got to imagine that the way you look at
the world,
the way you see things,
many,
many steps ahead.
Do you see any sort of a logical
conclusion to this process?
Do you see any light at the end of the
tunnel or do you see an impossible to
avoid conflict?
Like do what?
What do you see when you look at this
whole thing?
Long term.
While I would say I can't look at it
longterm,
and the reason for that is that,
and this is why I get a kick out of all
the KEC Keka Stan Boys,
you know,
I do believe that we're in a period of
chaos.
What's a Keck is tech.
Oh,
keck is a mythological country that's
ruled by chaos by the Keck who's a frog
frog.
As it turns out.
So I don't know about this.
You need to look them up.
That's a big internet thing.
Pakistan,
yeah.
Big Internet thing.
All know,
but the frog and the frog,
the trump frog.
Pepe the frog who has apparently so
distraught that his frog has been used
to align them off and killed them off.
What?
Good luck.
He didn't.
All right,
so that's stupid because that's not who
were,
who were using pepe.
I haven't got the story quite right,
but I'll get it mostly right.
The people who were using Pepsi as a
meme,
art is used.
Yeah,
that public of Keka Stan,
so they use this symbol,
k e Dot k to replace lol,
and the reason they did that was because
k e k in Korean means lol,
and so it was just this little joke.
Keck K,
e,
k.
well then somebody found out these were
people who were using pepe.
Remember it's a frog.
Then people found out that Keck was an
Egyptian God and he was a frog and he
was between categories,
sort of like a transsexual by the way.
He was between categories and so now
they have this republic of Keck and it's
ruled by this Egyptian God whose name is
cat,
who's a frog.
Hold on,
go back,
go.
Don't keep changing this.
Jamie's doing this in the background
while you're talking,
but look at this.
There's a frog with a make America great
again hat and he's got like a tombstone.
It says those who served in the meme
2015 and 2016.
We are the gods of the great meme war.
We are the shit posters.
The Legion of Keck,
we are the internet,
the death of the normies,
lapels and CAC.
We are one way or the fuck is going on
that.
That is the question.
That's the question you asked me and my
answer was,
I don't know.
We're in a period of chaos.
We in a period of chaos and in a period
of chaos,
the time horizon shrinks because no,
because the outcome is uncertain whether
this seems to be truly
embracing chaos.
I mean just that statement.
The frog that Donald Trump thing with
the hat on.
This is.
This is one of the things it seems to me
to be a reoccurring feature in this
whole chaos ballet that we're watching
play out,
is that people are enjoying the fact
that Donald Trump sucks as a president.
They don't feel threatened by it.
They like it and they don't like it
because they want to burn this mother
fucker to the ground and torch this
thing and like a phoenix.
We'll arrives from the fire.
No,
no,
it's not that.
It's that they.
They are enjoying that.
It's falling apart.
This is why we are the shit posters.
Do you know what shit posting is?
Yep.
Jamie explained.
You're really good at explaining it.
You're posting for like literally no
reason other than to get someone mad.
It's almost like trolling,
but it's like a separate level of
trolling.
Right?
That's a good way to say it.
Yeah.
That's a good way of provocation for its
own sake.
Jamie's the first person to tell me
about posting.
I wasn't
aware until about what a year ago.
Yeah,
I think it was.
preelection time.
I did not know.
So I mean there's rules for operating in
chaos,
right?
Because that's when you're in the belly
of the beast or the belly of the whale
and you're underwater,
you're in the underworld,
you're in the underworld and chaos and
so that's a really cool thing to know
Joe.
So imagine that the normal world of
mankind is inside that dominance
hierarchy where everything is going well
because nothing abnormal is happening
and you're getting what you need and you
want and you're conscious knowledge
suffices,
right?
Okay.
But then something tilts in that
structure no longer works.
So where do you end up?
You end up in underworld.
That's what happens when your partner of
20 years has a,
has a long term affair and you find out
about it.
It's like you thought you knew where you
were but you didn't,
and now that you found out you don't
know where you are when you don't know
where you are,
you're in the underworld.
Woo.
Right,
and that's where the unconscious forces
play.
Those are the gods.
That's why there's gods in the
underworld,
and people go to the underworld all the
time.
It's chaos and fear and depression,
hopelessness and imaginative.
This,
it's everything.
It's KLM is terrifying to people.
Terrifying and promising,
terrifying and promising because dragons
have gold because it's always the
unknown has two things.
Just like the future.
It's like lookout.
It'll do you in and look out.
It offers everything to you.
That's the underworld.
That's why the hero always goes into the
underworld to find a cave full of gold
that's guarded by a dragon in the
hobbit.
Literally Peel will fly.
That's the oldest story of mankind.
It's really the our oldest story and so
that the underworld is chaos.
It's chaos and down there there's all
sorts of play of possibility and the
reason the frog with a was the guardian
of chaos is because of the frog is this
thing that doesn't fit into categories
you see,
because it's partly water.
It's partly land.
It's tadpole,
yet it's,
it's adult,
right?
So it's like a fish and then it's like
an animal doesn't fit and it's things
that don't fit that blow apart the
categories,
right?
Well,
that's what the transsexuals due to the
category of gender for example,
and that puts you in this state of
chaos.
It puts you in this state of chaos and
that's what we're in now.
We're in a state of chaos and so what
are the rules for operating in a state
of chaos?
While as far as I can tell,
the fundamental rule when operating in
chaos is tell the truth.
So for example,
if you will,
for the people that want to navigate
this successful.
Yep.
All you've got,
that's what you've got as a,
as a shield and a weapon and,
and,
and that,
that's the guideposts.
That's the,
that's the way through.
When you see that hero stories all the
time,
you know,
so it's its allegiance to the truth,
but the truth is a strange thing.
It's a very strange thing.
Often the hero in a,
in a story has to assimilate their dark
side before they're capable of telling
the truth.
Right?
In the Hobbit,
for example,
he has to become a thief,
right?
Because he has to get tough.
That's the thing.
Also,
the thing about telling the truth is
that it's not for.
It's not for the naive,
not at all,
and partly because it burns off
deadwood.
It's partly because it hurts people's
feelings.
It's a sword.
So you have to be a warrior.
Wow.
A truth warrior
in this time of chaos,
right?
What emerges from this,
Sometimes sometimes it's catastrophe.
That's the thing about these categories,
they're real,
they're real.
And you know,
the optimists that I hear say,
well,
depending on the swings and then it
swings back and I think yeah,
well sometimes it,
it takes 100 years to swing back and it
takes a hell of a lot of people out on
the way and sometimes it never swings
back at all.
So you know,
sometimes people go out to fight a
dragon and it just eats them or it burns
them and that's the end of that.
And like we're in an unstable period of
time at the moment in a transition
period of some sort.
I can't put my finger on it,
but I know that that's partly why what
I've been saying has been resonating
with people because obviously it's not
about pronouns.
Well it is.
It is.
Except
language turns out to be about a lot
more than like,
you can't take a little thing like the
desire to transform pronouns and think
that that's a little thing.
It's not a little thing.
It's also your disagreement with this
use of these new gender pronoun words
they're trying to force on.
People has opened up this discussion
where you can enlightened people on your
very deep understanding of human
psychology.
It's not just simply this gender
pronoun,
disagreement.
You're transphobic,
you're a racist,
you're a trans phobic piece of shit.
It's this opportunity now because of
this.
That mean essentially they fucked with
the wrong dude really to say it the
right way because your.
Your understanding of this,
this tee shirt,
it's not shallow in any sense of the
word.
I mean to engage you in this,
this battle of rhetoric is it allows you
to expose your very deep understanding
what the problems that are going on
right now with human beings in general.
Well,
it looks,
it looks like that to me because what
happens
as far as I can tell with my youtube
channel say is that people are often
pulled in because of the social justice
warrior stuff,
but then they see I have all these other
videos and they're curious about me
partly because people are calling me
names and so then they watch a video or
two and they think,
hmm,
I haven't heard that before.
You know,
and then they watch a bunch of them and
then they write me and say,
man,
that was really helpful.
And I say thanks.
I'm really happy about that because I
am.
Are you in an unmanageable position now
though?
As far as responding to people
because like I try to respond to people
but I can't.
It's not possible.
I would imagine over the last few months
it must be just overwhelming.
Yeah,
the.
Yeah.
Well I've given up trying to keep up on
my email.
It's just not.
My wife helps me with that and I've had
some other people helped me but you
know,
what I do is I look and I try to say
thank you to people and write them a
couple of lines when I have a moment,
but you know,
because I can't get to all of it.
They just come in by the position and
it's too bad because people are writing
me very heartfelt long letters.
They're often brilliant.
Frequently like amazing letters telling
me,
you know,
their experiences with the authoritarian
left or or,
or the way they've been cornered in one
way or another or or how starting to
clean up the room changed their life.
That's quite fun because it's something
I always tell people to do instead of
going out and protesting Jesus.
I just can't stand up the room.
Yeah.
Meaning,
well,
my sense is is that if you want to
change the world,
you start from yourself and work outward
because you build your competence that
way.
It's like,
I don't know how you can go out and
protest the structure of the entire
economic system if can't keep your room
organized.
Yeah.
It's not an issue with people though,
that they always want to enact some sort
of control over the outside world when
they're inside is all fucked up.
People that are the most adamant about
it.
Well,
I think there's some truth in that.
I think there is truth in that.
I mean,
people try to change the outside world
for lots of ways,
but many of those ways aren't just pure
good.
But you know,
I thought about,
well,
I made a video call which was called
message to millennials where I was,
it was called how to change the world
properly,
a bit of a on the potential site I
suppose,
but I was trying to produce something
that was a counter position to this idea
that what you should do is go out and
fix up other people.
You know,
that's just not right.
There's a new testament line about that.
Something about,
you know,
not worrying too much about the log in
your neighbor's eye or about the speck
in your neighbor's eye.
When you have a log in your eye.
It's like,
yes,
no kidding,
but you know,
do you really want to,
do you really want to face that?
So what I've thought about is that,
well,
what you start to do is you start to
tell and act out the truth locally,
like within the domain of your actual
competence.
You know,
because the world presents itself as a
series of puzzles,
some of which you're capable of solving
and some of which you're not.
And you have many puzzles in front of
you that you could solve,
but you choose not to.
You know that those are the things that
weigh on your conscience.
It's like,
you know,
I should really do this,
but you don't.
It's like,
so I had this idea a long time ago
because the world is a pretty dreadful
place.
I thought,
well,
what would the world be like if people
stopped avoiding the things they knew
they should do?
You know?
Because the question is how much are we
contributing to the fact that life is a
as an existential catastrophe and a
tragedy?
How much is our own corruption
contributing to that?
How it's a really worthwhile question.
Things you leave undone because you're
angry,
you're resentful,
you're lazy,
you have inertia.
Well,
you consult your conscience and it says,
well,
you know,
that place over there could use a little
work.
It's the same as working on yourself and
so you clean that up because you can.
Then things are a little clearer around
you and you're a little better off
because you've practiced a bit and and
so your little stronger and then
something else manifests itself and
says,
well,
maybe you could like take a crack at
fixing me up to,
so you decided to do that and then that
gets a little bit more pristine and soon
and it's humble because you're not
exceeding your domain of competence.
You know?
It's like,
don't be fixing up the economy.
Eighteen year old,
you don't know anything about the
economy.
It's a massive complex machine beyond
anyone's understanding and you mess with
it at your peril.
So when can you even clean up your own
room?
No.
Well,
you should think about that.
You should think about that because if
you can't even clean up your own room,
who the hell are you to give advice to
the world?
Very,
very important thing for people to hear
is a very important thing for people to
hear it so many times.
I mean,
here's a perfect example that people
understand and be able to resonate with.
It'll resonate with them rather when you
see people that have a lot of
inspirational memes on instagram and
facebook through almost all fucked up.
L Ron Hubbard was completely insane and
was self-diagnosing and one of the
things he was trying to do,
I mean if you read Lawrence Wright's
book going clear,
he was clearly trying to fix himself in
creating this religion,
this religion that was a lot of it based
on self help principals that he took
from other sources that you see from a
lot of these people that are like,
you didn't mean just this real
legitimately motivational people that
find great benefit in being an example
of powerful,
strong example and they find great
comfort in showing people the methods
that they've used in order to improve
their life.
Like your own self auditing system that
you're promoting.
Yeah.
So it's not just,
it's not that they're all that.
It's all a,
it's all a not real or you know.
No,
there's not like there's no way that
people can improve them.
Quite the contrary.
They people can improve themselves I
think to a degree that we don't
understand.
You know,
because a human being for better or
worse,
this is something potential as well as
something actual that's really weird,
that idea of potential because it's not
actually measurable,
are tangible,
but we seriously believe it's something
like the idea of spirit,
you know,
by potential.
Yeah,
but people believe in it.
You see,
because I might say,
well,
you're not living up to your potential
and you might disagree,
but you would definitely understand the
statement and you think,
well,
what is this potential?
It's like,
it's not actual.
It's not real,
but it is,
isn't it though?
If you see someone,
especially artistic,
like you see someone who may be self
sabotage with drugs or alcohol or
personal chaos,
but they can create amazing music,
but they never get it out.
You see that oftentimes with the artists
and oftentimes you see that after
initial success,
you'll see some amazing motivation early
in their career.
Then initial success and then self
sabotage after the fact,
not realizing their potential.
Obviously they've hit some sort of a
frequency with a resonate with people
that appreciate them.
Authors,
you see that with musicians,
comedians,
uh,
all sorts of people to create things and
then they're not living up to their
potential because they've allowed the
demons to take over the inner workings
of their mind,
you know,
so and again,
I'm not talking.
There's a lot of sincere people that are
motivational people that I follow.
I think there's a lot of people out
there that are then they take a great
pleasure and expressing to other people
the things that have benefited them.
So I don't,
I don't want to sell them short.
Well,
see,
this is part of the reason I liked the
psychoanalysts say Freud Ngo,
because as an I would say particularly
young because I haven't read anyone I
regard as deeper than you.
He's terrifying,
truly terrifying.
But,
but here's one of the things that
differentiates from the typical self
help person I really love this,
is that he believes that the pathway to
completion as a human being is through
the,
is through the embodiment of the monster
embodiment of the monster.
That's the discovery of the shadow.
You see so young didn't believe that you
could be a good person until you
realized your capacity for evil.
I don't mean acted it out in the world,
but understand that it's possible.
Well,
not only understand it,
but then to bring it under your control.
You see,
because there's a big difference between
someone who's naive and is a good
person.
They're naive,
they're a good person because they can
not be there like a domesticated house
cat.
There's nothing.
They don't even have the capacity to be
bad,
so there's no morality in that.
The morality comes when you're a monster
and you can control it,
and that's the union encounter with the
shadow.
So young said,
for example,
that the roots of the shadow go all the
way down to hell,
and what he meant by that is that you.
You can think about it literally.
You think about it metaphorically.
We'll just think about it
metaphorically.
It's like if you start to understand who
you are,
then you understand the Nazis and who
wants to understand the Nazis.
You know,
I can understand sex criminals,
I can understand them,
right?
I can understand Nazis and the reason
for is because I can see that as an
aspect of myself truly,
but one of the things that so inter and
it's terrifying to realize that,
which is why it's terrifying to realize
the shadow,
which is why people don't do it.
It's no wonder they don't do it.
You know,
it's a,
it's a horrible thing to realize that
you're human and what being human means
like Angel,
like Christ to Satan.
That's the human being.
And you might say,
well,
those aren't real.
It's like,
okay,
well they're figments of the imagination
that the human race constructed to
describe themselves.
Find that.
Does that make it less frightening?
I don't think so.
So,
and it's not.
It doesn't make it any less frightening.
If you take those two extreme seriously
and he might say,
well,
who's going to take the Christ extreme?
Seriously?
It's no problem,
man dispense with it.
He tried getting rid of the other side.
See how you do with that.
So yones idea that you find so
compelling
was essentially that one has to
understand their potential for horrific
behavior.
That it almost exists in all of us,
that it's a facet of,
of just the human.
Well,
look,
I know partly why you're so popular.
It's because you're a monster.
I mean,
look,
I watched what you did to the
Kardashians on your,
on your,
uh,
engender on your comedy show,
man.
You did this whole gargoyle thing.
Yeah.
You remember,
you laugh.
Yeah.
I see.
You can even laugh about that.
I mean,
it was horrifying to be.
You were coached up on the back of this
chair.
It's horrifying to do.
Oh yeah.
I couldn't believe you did it.
Well,
the problem
doing it is this is going to sound
fucked up,
but while I'm doing it,
I'm not thinking I'm doing a comedy
sketch.
This is what's fucked up about it.
While I'm crouched there.
I'm thinking like a demon.
Like,
while that's the reason why I do it that
way.
The reason why do it in the like,
I'm a very flexible,
right?
So it's one of the reasons why I do it
in almost because I want it to be in an
almost a w,
w,
W in a way that you don't imagine human
beings moving,
you know,
that you,
it's like it,
it confuses the mind because it's not
standard human movement.
And then on top of that,
the way I'm thinking and then just like
explosive.
Like when he yells out nonsense,
and I say he because I don't think of it
as me,
I really think it's,
it sounds so pretentious,
but while I'm doing that,
my brain goes into another place.
Oh,
it's real.
You can't do.
You can't do that unless you're a
monster.
It's a.
But it's also the thing.
See very happy.
When I retired it,
by the way,
I was really quite taken aback.
I was very impressed by it.
I thought it was hilarious to begin
with,
but the fact that you would go there,
I thought that was really interesting.
And comedians are like that because they
go into dark places.
They're tricksters.
They're a mediator between the normal
world in the world of the gods.
They're tricksters.
So it was very funny to watch you do
that and I wondered how far you would
let yourself get into it.
But I think part of the reason that
you're appealing to people,
if you don't mind me saying this,
you know,
I'm not trying to be forward
particularly,
but I thought about it a lot,
is that you're a tough guy and you tell
the truth,
but it's both of those together.
That's what's doing it because you know,
people don't look at us and think like
holier than thou preacher,
that isn't what they think.
They think tough guy who's trying to
figure things out like right on.
That's good.
That's a good year.
A good figure for the times because this
whole war against the fellow egocentrism
need calls forward.
People who are like you.
If we're lucky.
And those are guys who have this warrior
end because you know,
you're a fighter.
So.
And if you're going to be a fighter,
you have to want to win and you have to
want to hurt people.
I mean,
not for the sake of hurting them.
That's what makes you different than an
evil person.
But you have to have that capacity,
you have to develop that and you know
that's the step on the way to
enlightenment,
weirdly enough,
because that isn't what people think.
Well,
I definitely think that truth is a
valuable commodity in this very bizarre
time and I think that's also one of the
reasons why you are very popular as a.
You have stuck your neck out in a world
that does not encourage it,
nor nor academia.
Not only does it not occurred,
it encourages the exact opposite.
Encourages you to stick your head in the
books and just to in some way,
shape or form.
Go with the tide like whichever way it
is and get your tenure and just.
Yeah,
well it's intellectual pride,
you know,
but I don't consider myself an
intellectual precisely.
What do you consider yourself?
What is an intellectual if you're not,
how about nobody?
Well,
the thing,
see,
because my ideas aren't disembodied.
I act them out.
But to be an intellectual romantic in
some sense.
Well,
I don't live in my head exactly and an
influential some degree,
but what is an intellectual do then you
say,
do you think of it as a pejorative?
When you think of the term intellectual,
do you think of it as a limited person?
Well,
it's a funny thing in this book called
zero through strip.
Nisha has is his Zarathustra come down
from a mountain top after being
enlightened and he sees this,
he goes into the public square and
there's this little tiny being there
like an inch high and it has a gigantic
ear on it and it's talking and people
are gathered around listening and that
was sort of niches metaphor for an
intellectual,
mostly little except maybe the rational
faculty or something like that.
Expanded to monstrous dimensions,
unbalanced in that manner and,
and,
and prone to become the subject of
totalitarian.
That's the worship of the rational mind
that the Catholic church always warned
against.
You know,
it's not like the Catholic church.
Of course I have to say that I won't
even say it or you don't need to know.
That's right.
So,
but the point is they had a warning and
the warning was that the rational mind
like to fall in love with its own
creations.
Right?
So the term intellectual,
the problem is that it identifies one
aspect and it it,
it sort of defines one aspect of
behavior and thinking only one.
Yeah,
it's the intellect as well.
What happens is,
is it's like,
it's like the intellect is raised to
the,
to the status of highest God.
That's the right way to think.
Seeing the God idea here.
Here's another way of thinking about it.
That's quite cool.
I learned this from you and you can take
it for what it's worth.
I'm the highest ideal that a person
holds consciously or unconsciously.
That's their God.
It functions in precisely that manner.
And people might say,
well,
I don't believe in God.
It's like,
well,
it depends on what you mean.
Like I know I'm not being,
I'm not being foolish about that.
It's like we're very complicated
creatures and we're run by all sorts of
very strange things down there in the
unconscious.
You know,
and the Greeks thought we were the
playthings of the Gods because we serve
lust,
we serve thirst,
we serve hunger,
we serve rage,
you know,
and those things all transcend us.
So that's why they were gods.
You know,
rage.
That's the war.
God.
Well,
why is it a god?
it exists forever.
It exists in all people.
It takes them over and directs their
behavior.
It's a god.
Well,
you can.
You can quibble about the details.
No,
it's not a god.
Okay,
fine.
It's a psychological force to people get
too hung up on that one word.
Well,
they don't.
They don't really.
We have to think about it functionally
to some degree.
We have to think about what that idea
means.
What?
I mean,
we had that idea forever.
It isn't just some superstition.
Jesus,
we've got to be more sophisticated than
that man.
You know,
and that's partly.
Well,
this is partly what,
what I think is unfortunate about the
new atheists,
let's say,
is they don't take the damn problem
seriously.
They think,
well,
Christianity,
that's just a bunch of superstition.
It's like,
really?
No,
sorry,
that's just not deep enough,
man.
So what it really is is the accounts of
people trying to work out the issues of
being a human.
Let me give you another example.
This is so cool.
It's northrop Frye who is a biblical
scholar in at the University of Toronto.
This was.
This was one of his elucidations of the
structure of the Bible.
The Bible is actually a story and which
is weird because it's a whole bunch of
different books written by a whole bunch
of different people edited kind of Willy
Nilly over thousands of years and then
assembled,
you know by committee.
It's a really strange book,
but it has a narrative structure.
So that sort of emerged as a collective
decision across these thousands of
years.
So the Old Testament.
Here's the rough story.
In the Old Testament,
Israel is sort of a middle power and it
rises to power,
so and domination and then it a profit
or rises and says,
look,
you guys are all successful now.
You starting to get corrupt.
You're not paying attention to the
widows and children.
You're not running your state according
to the superordinate principle.
You might say,
well,
the superordinate principal doesn't
exist.
It's like,
okay,
keep it running it that way and see what
the hell happens.
That's what the prophet says.
Usually at the risk of his life.
He says that to the king,
so I find you don't believe in God.
You don't believe in the superordinate
principle.
Let's say that the superordinate ethical
principle,
no problem.
Keep doing what you're doing.
Let's see what happens.
What happens is in real gets wiped out,
you know,
and then for generations it's enslaved
or its population is being destroyed and
then it sorta climbs back up to power
and then it gets powerful for a brief
period of time and it gets corrupt and
profit comes up and says,
you remember that superordinate
principle that you made a covenant with?
You're not paying any attention to it
anymore.
You better look the hell out and
everyone ignores it and bang.
So it's,
it's order,
corruption,
chaos,
order,
corruption,
chaos.
That happened six times now.
So here's the night.
There's an idea behind it.
The idea,
because the state keeps rising.
There's an idea that emerges out of
that,
that the aim is the perfect state.
That's a utopian dream that arises out
of that.
Let's call it learned process over
thousands of years.
If we could only get the state perfect.
If we could only get the state of
perfect,
well,
let's say like the state of Israel or
the or the Russian state,
the communist state.
If we could only bring utopia in at the
political level,
our problems would be solved.
Well then what happens is there's a
transition in conceptualization that
happens with the new testament and the
new testament conceptualization is,
wait a minute,
the state isn't salvation.
The individual is salvation.
Now you say,
well,
we're going to just throw that out.
Are We?
That was a hell of a discovery man.
It was a and then there's more to it.
It's not only is the individual
salvation,
it's the truthful individual that
salvation you think of how difficult a
concept like that is to develop.
If there's anything less self evident
than that,
you know,
because you think,
well,
who's going to run the dominant target?
It's like the biggest bloody monster
with a club.
It's like,
no,
it turns out those are unstable.
Those societies are unstable.
They don't work.
They collapse into chaos.
They get corrupt,
they lose sight of the superordinate
principle.
Whatever that is.
The stable solution is the individual
that tells the truth and it's taken us
forever to figure that out,
and that's partly what the
postmodernists thereafter.
That's their anti fellow egocentrism.
That's why they skitter off and hide in
the radiology.
They're afraid to come out.
They're afraid to be seen.
They're afraid to speak because they
have nothing to say,
so we have to get sophisticated about
this stuff or we're going to throw it
away without understanding it.
It's.
It's unbelievable like that stories.
It's,
it's the story upon Western civilization
is the story upon which Western
civilization is founded.
That's why Nisha said when God was dead,
that everything would collapse into
chaos.
He didn't say that triumphantly.
He knew what was gonna happen,
so to Dostoevsky.
That's why I admire those people so
much.
They knew what was coming,
so what I've been trying to do,
and I've been guided in large part by
young because he was the first seed
young took niches problem,
seriously neat.
You said,
look,
we're losing our faith.
We're losing our ability to relate to
the superordinate ethical principle,
and he actually blame Christianity for
killing itself with the,
with the sword of truth that it had
produced said,
so we're going to lose this,
and it's big trouble.
Make no mistake about it because our
whole society is founded on those
principles.
We get rid of the animating spirit at
the base of it.
We're going to lose all of it.
So and niche.
You thought,
well,
we're gonna have to become superhuman to
manage it.
Not.
That's where his concept of the overman
comes from,
or the Superman,
which the Nazis sort of pulled off and
parodied.
I would say now young,
you see human was a student of niches,
not directly,
but very much influenced by him.
Young thought that Nisha was wrong,
that we couldn't create our own values
because look,
it's so hard to create your own value.
So let's say you're kind of an
overweight guy and you decided to go to
the gym for your New Year's resolution.
It's like you don't.
You go twice and then you stop and it's
because you can't create your own
values,
right?
It's hard.
You're not your own slave.
You can't just tell yourself what to do.
You have a nature.
And so young's idea was while that we
had to go back to the mythology,
we had to go back to the stories.
We had to go back into the underground
unconscious chaos and lift out what we
had forgotten and that's what he was
trying to do with his psychology and
he's done it very effectively.
The very,
very effectively.
He was a revolutionary thinker but very
difficult to understand.
And so I've been working with ewing's
ideas for a long time trying to,
I would say make them more rational and
articulate.
Not Believe me,
that's no critique because every time I
go back to young,
which I do from time to time thinking
I've kind of mastered him.
I learned a bunch of stuff that I didn't
know.
So.
But so what I've been trying to do is to
resurrect God.
I'm trying to resurrect the dormant
logos,
I suppose if you have to put it that
way.
That's I'm trying to do
and it's mostly in mostly in men and
they're starving for it because I could
mostly in men.
I don't know.
That just seems to be what's happening.
Like about 90 percent of my viewers on
youtube are men,
but then when I go speak publicly,
it's all men.
What the hell are they doing?
Come in to hear somebody speak.
Men Don't do that,
right?
Women do that.
And so.
And then I talked to them about truth
and responsibility and their eyes light
up because it's like no one ever
mentioned that before and now it's.
It just boggles my mind.
I'm asking you because I feel like
that's a.
That is a gigantic theme today that men
searching for some sort of reason or
some sort of,
I guess without using,
without a better word,
path,
some sort of path.
I mean it seems to be very,
very prevalent today in almost all,
all walks of life.
Men feel disenfranchised with this world
that they find themselves stuck in.
There's a reason that superhero movies
are so popular,
you know,
that's polytheism.
The return of polytheism for all intents
and purposes.
I mean,
what the hell are those things?
They're demigods.
Obviously one of them is thor for God's
sake.
I mean account more obvious.
Could it be,
you know,
and so the.
You might say,
well,
who's the leader of the Demi Gods?
Because that's the person you really
want to follow,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
Well,
the evolutionary answer to that is,
well,
the evolutionary answer to that as far
as the Christian route went,
was Christ,
but there's been lots of embodiments of
that.
For the Mesopotamians,
it was Marduk.
Marduk was the savior figure.
He had eyes all the way around his head
and he spoke magic words.
That was his fund.
That's what made them different from all
the other gods.
And he was elected by,
other than all the other gods to be
their king.
And then he went out and fought tie
matt,
who's a great dragon and made the world
out of her pieces.
One of his names was he who makes
ingenious things out of the combat with
Time Matt.
Well,
that's what human beings do is they go
out into the unknown,
into chaos,
and they make ingenious things out of
it.
That's what we do,
and so that he's the found Marduk was
the founder of,
of,
of Mesopotamian civilization,
and you could think about all those
tribes came together to make
Mesopotamia.
They will have to God,
and so then those gods went to war and
out of that war of God's image,
God emerged.
That was Martin and Martin is one of the
sources for the figure of Christ that
happened all over the place like you see
the admirable man.
Then you see 10 out broomball Ben and
you think,
wow,
those guys have something in common.
That's what you remember about Muci.
You remember the heroic things they've
done because they stick in your memory
because they fit the pattern and then
you start telling the story about the
heroic things that a bunch of them did
it all that mail debates together and
then you come out with your culture
here,
your God.
Now there's like 50 tribes,
they each have their own gods,
will all the way,
what are you going to do?
Then the gods go to war over centuries
and then they elect new God Marduk and
in the case of the Mesopotamians and
he's the thing that goes out and fights
the dragon of chaos can makes the world.
It's like,
yeah,
that's exactly what he is.
You do that with truth because truth
introduces you to chaos.
Why do you think though it's so much of
an issue with males as opposed to
females in our society.
Maybe females already have enough to do.
Really,
really like maybe.
Maybe men have to take this on
voluntarily.
That's what it looks like to me because
like you can,
you can screw around til you're 50.
You could still have a family,
you've got time and you can sit down and
do nothing if you want.
You can do it so,
but you shouldn't because it's horrible
to do that.
People who do it know it like it's
meaningless.
It's wild.
It's funny thing about meaninglessness.
This.
There's no such thing when people say
their lives aren't,
are meaningless,
that isn't what they mean.
They mean I'm in pain and anxious all
the time.
That's what they mean.
Those are meanings,
man.
You don't get neutral,
you know,
I'm just sitting around.
I'm not feeling anything.
It's like,
no,
I'm sorry that doesn't happen.
So when you say do nothing that your
life is meaningless,
if you're doing nothing,
what do you mean by doing nothing?
Well,
by not accepting any response,
by not lifting a great load,
by not acting out the archetype of the
hero,
that's what people are.
That's where men are.
If there's anything there or
mythological heroes,
if there anything through some path,
whatever it is,
lots of paths mean.
So look,
there's an old mid evil idea.
This is the idea of the imitation of
Christ.
This is something that young elaborates
on a lot.
He,
he believed.
This is one of the things that he said
was that you're,
you're the proper goal of a Christian.
Roughly speaking is to enact the,
the Meta pattern of Christ's life in
their own to make it their own story.
And so what did he mean by that?
Well,
part of it is c,
one of the things that characterizes the
mythological figure of Christ,
let's say,
is that he takes on the burden of
mortality voluntarily.
He accepts it as a precondition of
existence.
And we have to do that because otherwise
we get resentful.
Like life is hard.
Make no mistake about it.
People's lives are tragic.
You know,
if you pick a random person off the
street and you ask them about their
life,
man,
usually there's things that have
happened there.
You know,
they just beggar the imagination.
It's no wonder people are angry and
resentful and bitter.
But the way out of that is to accept it,
to accept your mortality and that helps
you transcend it.
That's partly what the crucifix symbol
means because it was,
it was,
it was accepted voluntarily.
You have to accept your death
voluntarily.
That's part of the path of the hero.
It's a very difficult thing to do
obviously.
Obviously.
What's your alternative?
Obviously,
you know,
I think people are constantly searching
for that thing that you just described.
The thing of meaning,
you know,
having meaning in this life and that
meaning has a different definition for
everybody.
I mean everybody's meaning your meaning
might be very different than mine or
Jamie's.
You kind of have to have your own path
and I think that's also one of the
reasons why people are so confused is
because you're thrust into an early age
to a very rigid system of education and
then have jobs and then of career
structure where you're in this place and
most people don't feel like that's what
they're supposed to be doing and we feel
very alienated by the very structure of
society that we are embedded in.
Of course,
of course.
Well one of the no,
there's two primary masculine
mythological figures and one is the wise
king and the other is the king who
devours his own son.
That's the district.
That's the,
that's the patriarchy that the feminists
are always talking about.
Well,
of course it's always there.
So society is a destructive force.
It doesn't care about you as an
individual.
It needs you to be part of society.
It needs you to adopt the norms and to
squelch your peculiar individuality and
be a cog and to be socialized and you
know to him yourself in and control
yourself and not be impulsive and yeah,
it's a tyrant,
but the thing is,
society isn't only a tyrant.
That's the thing.
It's like how about a little gratitude
in there?
Well,
you know people have a hard time with
this because we like it when a thing is
only one thing,
but society is always two things.
It's the thing that alienates you and
the thing that you're benevolent.
Father always now tilt.
Sometimes it tilts harder towards the
tyrant and now it's not so good,
but that's an archetypal reality.
So what do you have to contend with in
life?
This is why these are architectural
realities because everyone has to
contend with them.
You have to contend with yourself and
the adversary that's inside you,
that that seems to oppose your every
movement.
The fact that you're not,
that you just can't move forward
smoothly through life without being in
conflict with yourself.
So there's a hero in the adversary on
the individual level.
And then on the social level,
there's the wise king and the tyrant.
You're always gonna run into that.
I don't care if you're a Bantu tribes,
Manura,
a New York lawyer,
all those things you're going to run
into.
And then in the natural world you're
going to run into destructive element of
nature,
right?
That's the Gorgon.
You get you,
you let that thing get a glance at you
and you're one like frozen poppy.
But also there's the benevolent element
of nature that's feminine,
that's Mother Nature.
Both of those extremes.
So and that's the world.
That's the archetypal world.
And it's because it's eternal as far as
human beings are concerned,
those things are always there.
That's our true environment.
It's not these things we see around us.
There are,
they're lasting,
no time.
These other things last forever.
And that's what we're adapted to where
we're adapted to the things that last
forever.
So,
but yet we go through this finite life
searching for meaning.
Well,
and it's funny to note where meaning
seems to locate itself.
You want a meaning that justifies the
suffering.
It's something like that that's a
transcendent meaning.
It's like this,
this is hard,
but it's worth it.
Okay,
so what do you do?
Pick something worth it.
Right?
That's partly what I tried to get people
to do with that future authoring program
to say,
okay,
look,
here's a place to start.
You got your miserable self right now
it's like three to five years out.
Imagine what your life could be like if
you had what you would give yourself if
you were taking care of yourself,
what would life be like?
Just come up with an idea even about
that and so then people do that and then
they write out a plan to attain it,
and then the college kids are like 30
percent more likely to stay in
university if they do that,
especially if they're men,
because men need a purpose.
I think women have a purpose,
are they now they have two purposes.
You know they're going to have a family.
That's a major purpose man.
Like just give birth.
It's.
That's no joke.
And then you're devoted to something for
like 20 years.
You got your adventure right there.
Yeah,
but a lot of women find great offense in
someone's saying that,
especially a man saying that
mansplaining,
that a woman's purpose is to breed.
Right?
I mean,
isn't that a giant issue that a lot of
women have?
I didn't say that was the only purpose.
I know that you didn't.
Oh yeah.
People have an issue with it,
but it's like grow up,
you know,
if you're a sophisticated person as far
as I'm concerned,
how many important things are there in
life?
Well,
one of them is family.
Like it's as simple as that.
Now you might say,
well,
family isn't the end all solution.
It's like,
yeah,
well thanks for pointing that out.
You know,
I've dealt with plenty of pathological
families,
but it's a huge part of life.
You have a mother and a father,
you have children.
It places you in the world and any
society that.
Look,
there's a reason society's worship the
virgin mother and the child.
It's because societies that don't die
and so people say,
well,
you know,
that relationship between mother and
child isn't the only thing.
Okay,
fine.
It's still a sacred thing and you miss
it.
You miss it.
If you're female,
you miss that at your peril.
Now,
that doesn't mean there aren't women who
shouldn't miss it because maybe they
have another purpose that's that
transcends that,
but that's rare.
It's very,
very rare and I would caution any women
listening if they're young,
not to be diluted into the idea that
their career is,
that will be up such high quality that
it's self.
Evidently trump's having a family.
You have to have a hell of a career
before that's the case.
So
don't you think that's unique to the
individual though that some people just,
they'll be more satisfied and I mean,
depending on what they're doing
artistically or creatively or whatever
it is,
you can't make rules for the
exceptional,
right?
You know,
they do
what they're going to do.
Those are open.
Maybe those are open people.
They have genius level Iq,
like they're.
They're spectacular in some manner and
so there's a reason they're going to
step outside the norm.
They're shape shifters,
no problem.
There's always gonna be people like that
and we need them.
How they know when they're that well,
telling the truth is a good start
because then you don't fool yourself
about who you are.
You know?
That's another one of the things I tried
to think through is why you should tell
the truth so it's not self evident,
man,
smart kid.
The smarter the kid,
the earlier they learn to lie.
Lying is very powerful because you can
manipulate the world with your language
and then you can get what you want lots
of times or escape from things that you
don't want.
So why not lie all the time?
Well,
I think the reason is there's a bunch of
reasons,
but one of the myths is that you can't
trust yourself if you lie and there's
going to be times in your life where you
have no one to turn to except you.
And so if you've stuffed yourself full
of lies,
then you're going to be in a crisis one
day and you're going to have to make a
decision and you're going to decide
wrong and you're going to be in real
trouble because you won't have the
clarity of mind necessary to make the
proper judgment because you've filled
your imagination and your perception
with with rubbish.
So,
and if you really think that through,
you see there's this old idea in the old
testament that fear of God is the
beginning of wisdom.
And I kind of understand what that means
because one of the things say we do with
the future authoring program,
we offer people a little heaven.
It's like,
okay,
construct your ideal aim added.
Come up with a plan.
You get a modify the plan,
no problem.
You're going to do a bad job of it.
No problem.
Just do it.
Okay?
So then now you've got a goal,
and now you're approach systems.
Technically speaking,
the positive emotion systems that
motivate you are you are engaged because
they're engaged in relationship to a
goal and the more transcendent goal,
the more they're engaged.
But that's not good enough.
It's great to run towards something you
like,
but it's even better to run away from
something that terrifies you.
So then we ask people,
okay,
so here,
think about this real carefully.
Take all your faults and your
inadequacies and your hatred for life,
all of that,
and then imagine that gets the upper
hand and then think about where you
could be in three to five years.
Everyone knows,
hey,
some people know they'd be a street
person,
some people know they'd be an alcoholic,
some people know they'd be a prostitute
or a drug addict,
like everybody's got their own little
hell they could descend into with a fair
degree of rapidity and a fair bit of
enjoyment and people know that.
And so I say,
well,
delineate that out too.
So you know where you're headed when you
fall off the path.
And so then you're running away and
running towards like,
yes,
well that's heaven.
Inhale and you need it.
And they're real.
They're as real as anything that you
can.
It depends on what you mean by a real,
I suppose,
but there's real as you make them.
How about that and people can make hell
pretty real.
People do seem to construct these
pitfalls for themselves.
I mean,
self sabotage is one of the most common
things that you find in people that are
struggling.
I mean,
you would think that someone who is
struggling,
the last thing they'd want to do is help
themselves towards their own demise,
but it's super common.
Yeah.
Well I thought about that too,
and so you tell me what you think about
this as if you talked to people.
They say,
well,
I want to have a meaningful life.
Generally people want that,
but then you think,
well then why aren't you?
And then you think,
well,
what does it mean to have a meaningful
life?
Exactly.
And then you think,
well,
maybe it means that you have to take on
responsibility because you're,
your sacrifices have to be worth
something,
right?
It has to have some cows to have some
meat.
What you're aiming at.
It has to be something that can elevate
your worm,
like self to the level of tolerability.
You know?
You can say,
well yeah,
I've got all these flaws,
but look at what I'm trying to do.
That's the real ground of self respect.
Well,
I missed.
I'm off the track with the question.
Ground of self respect.
I can't remember what you asked me,
so we'll have to go to a different
topic.
What,
what,
how did we get on this?
We were um,
you asked about the evolutionary basis
of.
That was a long time ago.
I know it's a rabbit hole that just
doesn't disappear.
But where will we just now remember
where we were just now?
No,
sorry.
Distracted by something else that's
happening right now.
I'll give you,
let you know.
What is it?
Columbia just got fired by trump a
little bit.
Oh,
and a twitter is a about.
This is a little off topic,
but I mean,
you want to talk about a finger.
Oh,
I know.
We were talking about men.
Yes.
We're talking about men and what
motivates them.
Yes.
And so then we were talking about the
fact that,
you know,
when I'm speaking publicly now,
most of my audience is men and that
their eyes light up when they're.
So we were,
we were talking about the necessity of
taking on the burden of a responsibility
because people,
not only are we,
should we be acting out the archetype of
the hero,
but we should be carrying the weight
while we're doing it because we're,
we're like pack animals.
We're not happy without a wait.
And I think it's.
I do think it's something like they have
to justify your miserable existence.
Do you think,
and this is my theory about that,
I believe that there are certain human
reward systems that we have ingrained in
us and that have allowed us to survive
this long and that these reward systems,
a lot of them entail overcoming struggle
because struggle was inexorable.
It was a massive part of existence.
And that without struggle,
our body is almost like,
well,
how come we're not hug?
I'm not overcoming something.
Yeah.
Right?
So it's almost like a trick.
Like you have to trick your body and you
trick your brain and trick your
humanity,
your,
your very existence into having some
sort of a purpose in order to be at a
baseline.
Yeah.
Well,
I'm going to make sense.
It does make sense,
but I,
I don't.
I don't think.
I don't think it's a trick here.
Here's why I think that because I think
there is something irreducible about
suffering.
I think it,
it,
it speaks for itself as a reality and
unquestionable reality.
No,
nobody says to a child that's in severe
pain and that it isn't going to matter
in a million years.
Right?
The pain trumps everything.
So then it seems to me that attempts to
alleviate suffering trump everything.
So if you want to responsibility,
it's like,
there you go.
One try,
argue your way out of that.
It doesn't matter.
Fine.
Your suffering doesn't matter then
that's for sure.
No,
none of this suffering matters.
You're going to go down that road are
you know,
you know what?
You know what the face of someone who
says that no suffering matter matters.
Looks like it's not pleasant.
So there's no neutral position with
regards to that.
So you see the world is full of
unrequited suffering,
let's say,
and who knows how much of it is
unnecessary.
Certainly the stuff you create seems to
be unnecessary,
especially if he created purposefully
and people are doing that all the time.
So if you need a burden,
it's like,
how about how about dampening down the
unnecessary suffering a little bit about
trying hard to do that for the rest of
your life.
See if that'll do it.
And God only knows how far you'd get you
might get along waste,
man.
When,
when people talk about meaning though,
when you talk about suffering and this,
uh,
this idea like what is,
what is going on in the mind that
desires this difficult pursuit?
Like what,
what is going on?
Like why is that a part of being a
person?
Like why is it a part of your ultimate
happiness to have these obstacles to
overcome and these character developing
moments,
character,
building episodes in order for you to
manage life and to get through life with
the most amount of happiness.
There's a story about this.
I think it's a frog and the Scorpion.
You know the story.
Well,
the frog,
please.
Yeah,
well,
the frog,
the Scorpion convinces the frog to give
him the right across the river and the
frog says,
well,
you're a scorpion.
It's like,
you know,
I'm not going to do that because you're
going to nail me with your tail.
And the Scorpion says,
no,
if I do that when we're in the river
will both drowned.
So why would I do that?
So the frog agrees to ferry the Scorpion
across and they get halfway out and
Scorpion stings the frog says turns to
him with his dying breath and says,
why'd you do that?
And the Scorpion said,
well,
it's in my nature,
and that's the answer to your question,
is that it's in our nature.
That's what an archetype is.
We're the hero.
Archetype is the story of men.
Right?
But do you think that that nature,
because that is how we survived,
how over the millions of years will
evolve from lower hominids to being a
human being,
is that we needed to have the mechanisms
in,
in our very existence to overcome
struggle.
Then all of a sudden,
Joel,
maybe we chose it.
You know,
you think,
well,
I mean I think it is part of the
evolutionary process,
but look,
the thing about sexual selection or the
mechanisms that we talked about say
whereby the dominance hierarchy is the
selection mechanism for,
for the transfer of genetic material.
There's a choice in that if a group of
guys gets to get together and a leader
emerge,
someone,
everyone respects.
It's like an election.
Everyone voted on it.
We chose that particular type of person.
Well who is that?
Well,
that's the heroic type.
Human beings have chosen that and then
the women think,
oh look,
I heroic type.
It's like they grabbed them before
someone else gets it,
and so that's been going on forever.
So did we choose it?
Well,
the action of our choice across
millennia selected it.
These are things evolutionary
psychologists,
biologists don't think about.
They don't think about the role that
consciousness played in determining who
survived and how and why it's been going
on for a long time.
While they certainly know about sexual
selection by female choice,
you know,
but the full implications of that
haven't been thought through.
Like I've just really started to grapple
with the idea that the male hierarchy is
sexual selection device.
It's like the men are voting on well,
who,
which of us deserves to go sleep with a
woman.
It's like,
well you don't,
you're kind of a weaselly little snake,
so you know,
not,
not you.
It's like,
oh,
Joe,
Joe looks like quite the guy.
Let's put him at the top of the
hierarchy.
That's what men have been doing with
each other forever.
Isn't there more to it than that?
There's a lot to that because of.
The question is who is it that they're
electing,
but is it really just about sexual
selection?
That's a good question.
Joe.
Freud thought so.
Like it's half about that get say half.
Well,
you know,
there's the survival of the individual
and the survival of the species.
So those are the two things,
but in the.
But even with that sexual selection,
even with that,
say if a person does rise to the top of
the social hierarchy in that small
Dunbar's number of 250 people,
the person,
is that enough?
Does that person still need purpose?
Do they still need something in some
difficult struggle for them to feel
fulfilled?
For most of,
for most of human history,
that just wasn't a problem because you
had struggle constantly,
man.
Yes,
absolutely.
Any problem today that is that the
problem,
our lack of problems?
Sure.
It's something kierkegaard pointed out
like 150 years ago.
He said they'll come a time when
everything has been done so well for
everyone that the only lack,
the only felt lack will be for lack
itself.
Are you concerned because of that and
because you're acutely aware of this
issue or concern with this potential
future that we have in front of us with
artificial intelligence and virtual
reality in this need to live in a world
that's not real like I mean,
how many kids today listening to this
exist for a massive amount of their day,
watching video games,
playing video games,
playing the archetypal hero,
and I had a friend,
and this is a classic story.
I'll never forget this statement that he
said to me.
He was one of the managers at the comedy
store who's a very nice guy,
but he was addicted to video games,
which I have been in the past.
I was addicted to video games for a
couple of years,
might play them all the time.
I loved them.
There was so much fun,
but this guy,
he had it bad.
I was.
I had a career while I was doing it.
I managed to figure it out that this was
a massive waste of my time and get
through.
He didn't and when one day he was like,
I mean Pale,
like he hadn't been outside days and he
was hanging out in the back of the
comedy store and we were talking and he
was addicted to,
I think it was ever quest,
which was this crazy roleplaying game
that you just do and you just.
People would play it 18 hours a day and
he said something I'll never forget.
He said,
I'm so successful in the video game
world and so unsuccessful in the real
world.
I think it was like sitting there like
shaking his head.
It was like,
wow.
In the real world.
He was like very unfulfilled.
Couldn't find a girlfriend,
was struggling financially in the video
game world.
He was like,
some warlock is out there slaying
dragons and in and he found great reward
in that video game world.
I am very concerned that we will
literally almost be like in the matrix,
plugged into some artificial electronic
thing,
which I think these,
these video games that people are
playing all day long,
they're a precursor to that.
Don't get me along if you have great
self control.
They're very enjoyable,
they're fun,
they're great social time with you and
your friends get together,
you play and you have a great.
As long as you're actually being
productive and active in our everyday
life.
I don't really think there are a
problem,
but my concern is that they are a
precursor and that we are seeing the
beginning steps to this artificial world
that,
that we will be embedded in,
in the very near future.
Well,
you know,
we,
we decided already that we're in a
period of chaos and you know,
part of the reason I'm loath to make any
predictions is,
I mean that's one of the reasons.
It's like how many things need to be
going sideways at the same time.
Lots of things are going sideways.
Oh,
I have no idea what's going to happen.
I mean,
we're building autonomous cars.
Seventy,
like that's the biggest employment
category driver.
Yeah.
So what then you know,
but why?
Why worry about that?
There's 20 other things that are
happening.
They're just as revolutionary.
So what's going to happen?
Who knows?
I have no idea.
I think maybe I know how to steer the
boat.
You know,
that's all he tried to tell the truth
and maybe you'll get through it and
acted out as well because what else do
you have is not another fantastic sign
of chaos.
I say fantastic.
Not in a positive way,
but that Donald Trump is our president.
Now.
The president has who has had the
biggest problem with the truth that
we've ever experienced.
We've never experienced a president like
this where we know that he has a problem
with the truth and it's,
it's,
it's open,
it doesn't seem to funnies us.
He has an unstructured problem with the
truth.
He was preferred as a candidate to
someone who had a structured approach to
untruth.
Right?
Right.
So it's like,
pick your type of lie.
You can pick the ideal ideology,
power aiming lie or a new kind of or or.
Yeah,
a more personal lie.
Say if you're going to be cynical about
it.
Well,
it kind of lie to that didn't fit the
standard structure that we're accustomed
to and felt very disenchanted with.
Yeah.
Lower maybe a nakedly self-serving lie.
It's like,
oh,
thank God,
that's such a relief after the
totalitarian ideology lies.
Oh God,
when he said that way so fucked up.
That's obviously it though.
Yeah,
well that's definitely part of it and I
mean,
lots of people did.
I know people went into the voting
booth,
their hand was hovering over Hillary,
you know,
and it was shaking and they thought,
oh,
to hell with it,
trump.
And so,
and you know,
what's the sentiment that I can
appreciate?
So and so here we are,
but that's only the tiny.
That's only the tail end of the Dragon.
I mean,
yeah,
there's,
who knows,
who can look ahead.
This is a strange time we're in.
Maybe it's associated with Kurt swells,
prognostications,
you know,
I mean he,
he talked about the consequences of an
ever accelerating technological
transformation and you know,
I mean look,
just in the last 50 years we've had the
birth control,
the hydrogen bomb and the transistor
thrown out as it's like,
man,
those are some pretty wild tornadoes.
And,
and,
and that's just scratching the surface.
So the last 100.
I mean,
if you just go back to the beginning of
the 20th century to today,
I mean,
it's fucking,
it's unbelievable.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
in 18,
95,
the average person in the west lived on
a dollar a day in today's dollars.
In 18.
90 five.
Yes.
Really?
In today's dollars.
Yeah.
Wow.
No kidding.
Well,
that's the other thing with the people,
when they find out how little the rest
of the world lives on,
they find out that the top one percent
of the world makes about $34,000
us.
Yeah.
Well,
it depends on.
I know if you're,
you know,
for many people,
someone who's rich is someone who has
more money than them.
Right.
Which is one of the things I really find
funny about the,
like the radical left protests.
The campus is like
down with the one percent.
It's like,
Hey,
sunshine,
you're part of the one percent.
You're just,
you're actually a baby.
One 10th of one percent or or maybe one,
100th of one percent or you're just
angry because you're not there yet,
but you will be when you're 40 and you
know it and so does everybody else and
now instead of regarding yourself
properly as a fledgling member of the
elite,
you want to have it both ways.
You want to be fledgling member of the
elite and champion of the Undergrad
under privileged,
so how narcissistic can you get?
You want to have all the benefits of
having all the benefits and you want to
have all the benefits of having none of
the benefits because just all the
benefits isn't enough for you.
One thing that it's a reoccurring
subjects that I find incredibly
fascinating and it keeps coming up and
it's been brought up even more so lately
because of artificial intelligence and
automated vehicles and all these
different things that are happening that
they're going to be an erosion of jobs
and a subject keeps reoccurring and
that's universal basic income.
The idea of giving people,
giving everyone a certain amount of
money,
whether it's 12,000
or $18,000,
what do you.
What are your thoughts on that?
I don't know what to think about that.
You know,
it certainly it would require a
revolution in the way people consider
their lives and then maybe that rev w,
what do people do with leisure time?
What should you do with it?
Well,
leisure time.
It's like what is leisure time exactly?
Is it?
Is it sitting in a closet like discord,
discarded android?
I mean that's often how people respond
when they retire,
right,
but what they have to retire or would
they have their needs taken care of as
far as food and shelter and then be able
to pursue something that they actually
enjoy and are interested in because the
job that they were stuck in doesn't
exist anymore.
That's the question and I would say I
would say at the moment the data aren't
great.
You know what happens to a lot of men
who are unemployed now,
they've let say they've had that thrust
upon them involuntarily,
but most people who we would be talking
about would be in that situation is that
they get depressed,
they sit on the couch,
they develop chronic pain problems.
They start taking it will be it for the
pain problems and then soon they're
hooked.
Like it's not a pretty.
I mean I know that that everyone isn't
doing that,
but lots of people are doing that.
So that's.
Unemployment is as an in kind of a
different thing because you know,
well my thought is that unemployment,
if you've got something like universal
basic income,
I mean I'm born,
we're talking about a complete
revolution in the way society is
structured,
right?
Because if automation does come along
and artificial intelligence does come
along and it really is a situation where
a lot of the things that people do to
occupy their time in order to feed
themselves and shelter themselves,
they don't exist anymore.
It's unnecessary.
So you're not talking about unemployment
like Bob,
you're not a good enough lawyer.
You've been fired.
And now you're like,
God,
I'm a failure,
I'm depressed,
I am unemployed.
We're not talking about that.
We're talking about literally society as
we know it.
Having a complete reset.
Yep.
Yeah.
Well I don't.
I have no idea what to say about that.
I don't either.
That's why I asked you to look.
I mean,
there are people.
Here's the optimistic end.
I'll speak as a determinist.
I'm not a determinist,
but I'm going to speak that way anyways.
So there are lots of people who are
creative.
They're high in trade,
openness from the big five perspective,
they're going to go do creative things,
but there are lots of people who aren't
creative,
so I don't know what they're going to do
because it isn't going to be creative
things.
What do you think people.
Well,
why are people creative and noncreative?
Like are there people that are just.
Not that it's never been nurtured in
them that they have the potential to be
creative or do you?
Don't think so.
No,
no.
That the literature is pretty clear on
that.
I mean,
the traits are highly heritable.
They're modifiable,
but if you're really non creative,
it's like it ain't going anywhere for
you,
and the reason for that is creativity
isn't like.
It's not all sweetness and light,
man.
I mean the reason there are non creative
people because creative people often
died.
They're all doing like screwy things.
They attract attention from people.
They shouldn't attract attention from
the authorities.
You know,
creative people are revolutionary.
Well,
if tyrants don't really like
revolutionaries,
here's lots of reasons not to be
creative.
Even now,
like creative people,
it's hard to monetize your creative
creativity.
Artists have a hell of a time surviving,
right?
And,
and so,
so creativity has such as a.
it's a double edged blessing for sure.
And part of the reason that lots of
people aren't creative is because it's a
lot.
Let's think about it from an
evolutionary perspective is because it's
a hell of a lot easier not to be decked
out in bright colors when the predators
come along,
right?
You want to stay camouflaged against the
herd,
like a zebra.
You don't want to stand out.
I'll tell you a little story about that.
So I think I got this from Robert
Sapolsky and if I didn't I apologize,
but.
So let's say you're a biologist to go to
study some zebras,
you think people think,
wow,
those zebras are camouflage because they
have black and white stripes.
Well no,
that's not camouflage.
Lion is camouflaged.
It's golden.
It looks like the grass.
You can see a zebra like 15 miles away.
It's black and white.
Okay,
so you're looking at some zebras and you
think,
yeah,
I need to look at one zebra to figure
out what it's doing because I'm trying
to understand zebras.
So you look at a zebra and then you take
some notes and look up and you think,
oh God.
Which zebra was that?
Because the camouflage is against the
herd.
Just the idea that the camouflage is
against the herd.
That's such a useful idea to have in
your mind.
That camouflage is against the herd.
So you go up to the zebra in your jeep
and you've got to stick with a rag on it
and you put a nice daub of red paint on
the zebras haunch or you clip.
It seems like with a cattle clip and the
first thing that you know,
you get it the hell out of there and the
lions kill it because they can identify
the thing that stands out and organize
their hunter around it.
And so that's why there aren't creative
people.
I think that is a Paul scan.
I think it was a rear clip.
I remember.
I remember this discussion.
Yeah.
That it's also that the edge detection
animal,
like there's a,
there's a type of or pattern account
flash pattern called the asap and asap
camouflage doesn't look like trees.
You know,
when people think of pull up asap
pattern first light l I t,
m military camouflage pattern all
season,
all terrain can necessarily develop
that.
Hey,
they just stole it.
Congratulations.
Yes.
It's one of our,
I feel like we're all one.
I don't believe in borders.
Um,
it's actually for animals.
There you could see a psat and the
reason is animals can't.
They they only see in black and white,
like Predator prey.
Animals like deer and it's edge
detection that they're looking for.
And these things,
the hard lines of the black.
And the Brown and the lighter colors,
it throws off the.
That's fusion.
That's a different color.
That's a different type of camera.
But the asap is what we're talking
about,
which is right above it.
That leg.
Read it yet right there.
Bam.
Yeah,
that's it.
And I'm also wrong.
Canadians didn't invent.
This was the other stuff.
The military.
Other than that did a bunch of stuff.
I'm sure I'll give you guys A.
I'm a fan of Canada,
man.
I love it.
I really do love Canada.
I think you people up there just so much
nicer.
It's A.
I have struggled to try to figure out
why I've thought about it many,
many times,
but I think people in general in Canada
or I always say there's 20 percent less
douchebags in Canada.
I mean there's assholes everywhere you
go,
but I feel like Canada,
for whatever reason,
people were extremely polite.
Yes.
I wouldn't say,
well,
I don't know.
I don't see.
I'm not sure.
I'm not convinced of it because I often
think the same thing when I come down to
the U.
S that people are more polite.
Well that their.
That their level of customer service for
example,
but I think one of the differences
between Canada and the US is like all of
Canada in some senses like the midwest
of the United States,
you know,
so we don't have this,
we don't have this extreme culture that
characterizes the us with the late great
lows and the great highs were all were
like elevator music,
you know,
compared to a full symphony and there
can be some really tragic parts of the
symphony.
So you know,
if you want peace order and good
government,
that's our constitutional credo.
Then you know,
Canada's your place,
but it's a middle class,
middle of the road society and that has
some benefits,
you know,
it's nice and welcoming and,
and not to experimental and kind of call
them insecure and those are good things.
It's,
I don't think it's a place that is great
at dealing with excellence,
but know that's interesting.
Do you feel like excellence is
suppressed because people don't like
when someone stands out too much?
Ah,
yeah.
Well I think that's true everywhere,
but I think it's more true of Canada
than it is of us.
I think
it's celebrated a lot in the US.
I mean,
I think there's always going to be some
resistance,
especially from people that don't feel
like people always measure themselves
against someone if there's someone else
out there is just no some genius in some
form or another.
There's always going to people that
people that measure themselves against
that person and find themselves coming
up short so they try to attack that
individual.
Someone who has just catastrophic
success and some sort of a way.
Yeah,
that's another reason for the end for
people to be enemies of clear thought as
well because clear thought is a good
pathway to success and so if you could
go after people who think clearly,
it's another way of keeping the
dominance hierarchy nice and flat for
your,
for your delectation let's say.
Mm.
So that's the enemy of competence
element that I see as part of the social
justice warrior movement.
Right?
And the extreme lack of financial
success and yeah,
and even creative success.
Well,
and even the insistence that hierarchies
are always based on power.
It's like neuro.
The hierarchy of neurosurgeons is not
based on power or yet is obviously,
you know,
hierarchies are based to some degree on
power.
We don't have to be juvenile about it,
but you know,
the best neurosurgeons actually know how
to do surgery.
That's not just a power thing,
right?
The best farmer's Hay,
they grow food.
So there's no,
there's no appreciation for actual the
real world while there's no real world
in postmodernism anyway,
so that doesn't matter,
but there's no appreciation for
competence or the fact that there's
individual difference in competence even
though they're always talking about
diversity and there's a downplaying of
competition and the importance of
competition.
Definitely.
Oh yes,
yes.
Well that's.
Yes,
and that's something that's
particularly,
I think,
hard on men because men compete and they
compete.
Partly because women like winners.
I mean that's part of the reason.
So.
And you're shamed for that in this
postmodern view of the world.
Oh yeah.
Well,
you know the schools increasingly or non
competitive places.
It's like for a guy that means,
well,
let's tune out and go watch video games
because like,
if I can't win it this,
why should I play well to cooperate?
It's like,
well,
you know,
fair enough,
man,
but I'd actually like to try to win at
something.
Well,
how evil can you get?
it's toxic masculinity,
Jordan.
That one drives me fucking crazy.
Like what does that mean?
Toxic masculinity?
Toxic has an.
It has nothing to do in masculine or
feminine.
If something's toxic,
it's toxic.
There's no toxic masculinity.
If someone's evil,
they do something horrible.
If they're gingiss con or Adolf Hitler,
that's not toxic.
Masculinity.
That's an evil person has nothing to do
with the masculine and feminine.
Yeah,
well,
you know,
it depends on what your political agenda
is.
I mean,
men are more likely to be the type of
person that does something awful in
terms of dominating or war or violence.
It's almost in our nature in some way
because of all the things that we
discussed before,
we're more,
we're more likely to do something that's
really evident.
There's plenty of bullying that goes on
behind the scenes among women are
absolutely know it can manifest itself
in naked physical aggression and I
actually think that's hard on women in
some ways.
I mean my,
my daughter for example,
is always mad at my son because like not
chronically,
but you know,
he'd have a dispute with one of his
friends and maybe it would get physical
and then that'd be the end of it.
They'd be friends again,
you know,
there was a way,
there is a way of bringing it to a
conclusion and without that then things
can smolder on forever and that's really
rough.
You know,
some.
Sometimes the simplest solution is a
fight often and you know,
I'm not that deep so I know what you're
saying.
No,
but I'm embarrassed that I would even
think that I have to put some little
quote marks around your documented
developing person to.
You're talking about young people.
It is,
it is an issue,
this simmering and stewing of,
of disputes where they never come to a
head and they never get resolved.
Yeah.
It's a terrible thing.
Terrible thing.
It's part of hell for sure to have these
things that are just grinding away at
you all the time.
You know,
it's not.
It's definitely not.
It's not a good place to be in.
Good motivations don't come out of it.
That's for sure.
You've made some some statements and
we've had some.
You've had some conversations about your
role in academia and that you might not
necessarily be unstructured academia
forever,
that this might be an issue like that.
This is coming to a head.
You feel that way now?
Well,
the university,
I think what happened was the university
reacted towards me because a bunch of
people got irritated and organized and
you know when they're irritated way and
said that I was a bad person and
something should be done about me and
there was enough of them so the
university thought they needed to react
to that pressure.
That's a charitable way of interpreting
it but reasonable.
But then a bunch of people wrote the
university and said,
wait a second,
I agree with what that guy's doing.
You should leave them alone and not only
people from the general populace,
but soon after I posted the original
videos,
like the press was kind of a bivalent
about me for awhile in,
in the first two weeks or three weeks,
say,
after I released those videos and there
were the protests,
but then they started to look into what
I was doing and they thought,
oh,
it turns out that,
you know,
freedom of speech actually happens to be
quite important to journalists to.
And they came out like really radically
in support of me,
some of the major journalists in Canada
and a whole,
the whole post media system,
which was about a hundred and 50 or 200
newspapers.
And so the university had a reason to
back off and maybe they were happy to
back off.
I mean,
the Dean I was negotiating was,
you know,
he wasn't a bad guy.
He was an older guy.
I think he's in his seventies and
responding to pressure.
He didn't want a bunch of trouble and,
and he wanted the problem to go away
right now.
And that's what you do want for problems
to do.
But anyways,
all this public support I got gave the
university a reason to leave me the hell
alone,
so they decided to do that and partly I
suppose I was always reasonable during
the negotiations because I'm a
reasonable person and so,
you know,
when they met me they realized that I
wasn't the particular kind of monster
that I had been accused of being.
And so the university has left me off
and then so I was,
I had a health crisis in December that
more or less rectified itself by the
beginning of January,
but I wasn't sure that plus what had
happened to me because of these videos
and all the crazy response to them.
Um,
I wasn't sure I was in a sufficiently
together position to go back lecturing
in January.
I didn't even know for a while until
December if I was going to be,
let's say,
allowed to continue to lecture.
So it's very uncertain.
But I decided that it was better to get
back on the horse,
so to speak.
And so I started lecturing and the
students were very welcoming.
So thank God for that.
What is it like now when you're in
school,
is that a completely different
experience and before your notoriety
exploded?
Well,
there's lots of things that are
different about it.
I mean,
this,
lots of students,
there are lots of people who come to my
classes just to sit in the classes.
There's people who are stopping me all
the time in the hallways and wanting to
introduce themselves and that happens a
lot in public and in the strangest
situation.
So I'm rather unused to that.
Um,
the feeling at the university.
Well,
I haven't processed any of that yet.
I mean I would say I'm about seven
months behind in my understanding of my
own life.
No,
because things happen.
So many things happened from September
to now that I haven't had time to think
about any of them,
you know,
it's just,
and it's been a continual,
an absolutely continual,
um,
treadmill of trying to keep up with the
requests for speaking and the email.
And,
and I'm,
I'm supposed to be making these youtube
videos because I have people who are
supporting me for doing that.
So I'm trying to keep that up.
And then I'm trying to go speak when
people invite me,
but not all the time because of course
that's a lot of travel and so I'm trying
to recalibrate my life.
I'm trying to figure out,
okay,
I've got 10 million views on youtube.
Well what am I supposed to do with that
piece of information?
I've got 250,000
subscribers.
So what is,
what does that mean?
What,
what does that mean for what I should be
doing?
Maybe I should be doing nothing but
making youtube videos for them.
I don't know.
It's a tremendous violence.
It's unbelievable.
It's like it's,
it's unparalleled.
Yeah.
Just,
I mean think about it from in terms of
is there any other academic that has
ever
done anything remotely like that where
you have 250,000
subscribers on youtube in a relatively
short amount of time and then millions
and millions of views on your video?
I know,
I don't know.
I mean well it's ill defined territory,
right?
Because who knows what youtube is.
I mean your,
your presence.
I don't know what you make of your
presence.
I mean,
you told me,
I think that you're getting something
like 70 million downloads a month.
It's more than like 120 now.
Okay.
So you're getting a billion downloads a
year,
something like that.
More than that.
So what?
Right.
Yeah.
So what the hell.
So I could ask you,
what do you make of that?
Like are you the,
are you the,
are you the most powerful interview or
on the planet or are you the most
powerful interview that the planet has
ever seen because it.
Well,
the numbers would suggest so nobody's
had who has a billion of anything.
No one,
you know,
it's never happened.
So what the hell?
So what are you doing and why is it
working and where are all these people?
God.
Well,
what I do is just keep doing it.
That's all I do.
I just do what I do and I don't think
too much about it.
I enjoy it.
I try to talk to people like yourself
that I really enjoy talking to.
Or the guy before you was a bow hunter,
which I enjoy talking to him two very
different.
Very,
very different conversation.
Tomorrow I'm talking about a guy who's a
debunker or talking to a guy who's a.
He runs a site called metabolic.
We're going to talk about people that
believe the earth is flat.
Literally,
we're going to spend about two hours
debunking the flat earth theory that is
all over the Internet.
I don't know if you realize I've seen
it.
There is a rabid anti intellectual vibe
that's going on today and this is flat.
No wonder you know,
it's no wonder because the many of the
prominent intellectual types have become
prisoners of their own imagination.
You know,
it's.
This is partly what breeds that.
That terror of intellectual ism.
There's something,
there's something about it that's we
don't want to get too far away from our
bodies.
We don't want to get too far away from
her souls.
That's another way of thinking about it
and you know,
there,
there is this idea that as I said
before,
that the Catholics always warned about
is that the rational mind falls in love
with its own productions or even more
that it tries to elevate its productions
to the status of God and that's,
I mean,
that's really what Milton was warning
about,
at least in some sense in his book,
Paradise lost.
You know,
these utopias are human creations and
then people fall prey to them.
It's like idol worship really is very
much like idol worship and,
and it's no wonder people get skeptical
of the intellectuals because they're
producing these utopias that are fake
that they inhabit.
They're almost like the abstract
equivalent of video games.
You soul.
I
think you're right about that,
but I also think there's something else
going on.
I think people are aware of this chaos
that we described earlier and they're
terrified and they're cleaning to
nonsense because of that terror and
they're embedding themselves in these
fruitless pursuits,
chasing their own tail.
Hey,
I'm,
I'm on board with that man that chasing
your own tail.
That's a symbol of chaos.
Chaos is the dragon that eats its own
tail,
so that came spontaneously to mind when
you thought about that,
because it's a downward spiral man.
Yeah,
and the thing is is that as you,
as you retreat from the chaos into your
own little prison,
you get weaker and weaker and the prison
gets smaller and smaller and the chaos
gets bigger and bigger.
It's really an ugly pathway and you get
more and more bitter and resentful and
much more afraid of having your prison
walls breached.
It's a downward spiral and much less
interested in pursuing the truth or any
sort of objective reasoning and much
more interested in confirmation bias to
the extreme.
That's right.
That's exactly what happens.
I detailed out that process in my book
maps of meaning exactly that it's this
feedback loop pay because you,
the weaker you are,
the thicker the walls have to be,
but the thick you make the walls,
the less challenge you face in the
weaker you get,
so then the walls have to get thicker
and then you get weaker and the walls
have to get thicker and it's not a
pretty.
It's not a pretty picture man.
So.
Hmm.
Yeah,
that's what I think too.
Yeah.
Because.
And on that note we just to three hours,
we just did it.
This is my favorite podcasts of all
time.
Oh,
I just want to tell Ya.
Well thank you.
Thank you.
It was awesome.
I could I say it was my favorite podcast
of all time.
I have a much smaller domain of podcast
comparisons.
So we did.
This is like number 900 and what,
what is it?
Nine hundred 58.
I think you touched on some things that
made me think in a very unique way
today,
so thank you very much for that.
I'm going to listen to this one a couple
of times.
So thank you very much both for both
occasions.
I mean you provided a tremendous boost
to my presence,
so whatever comes of that is to be
blamed partly on you.
Alrighty.
All right.
Thanks brother.
You Bet.
Really appreciate it.
Good.
Yep.
Thank you Jordan Peterson.
Ladies,
gentlemen,
Cmr.